Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur mittlerweile 50. Ausgabe in dieser Gesprächsserie, ein kleines Jubiläum. Soweit ist es jetzt also schon gekommen. Und ja heute geht es an die Nase. Heute wollen wir uns ein bisschen in ein Universum einfragen, was uns alle permanent umgibt und betört und berührt und auch lenkt und leitet. Und warum das so ist und wie das so ist, das erzählt uns unser Gesprächspartner, ich begrüße Hanns Hatt, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo und guten Tag.
Herr Hatt, Sie sind Wissenschaftler hier an der Ruhruniversität in Bochum, wo wir uns gerade befinden. Leiter des Instituts für Zellphysiologie, wenn ich es jetzt richtig notiert habe. Habe gerade ein schönes Plakat gesehen im Flur mit so einer Zelle, wo Sie der Zellkern sind und Ihre ganzen Mitarbeiter drum herum. Ich kann mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass es auch ein entsprechendes Gewusel ist, hier die Forschung voranzutreiben?
Ja in der Tat. Also es war zumindest schon mal ein größeres Gewusel, vor etwa 10-15 Jahren, als wir etwas 60-70 Mitarbeiter hatten. Aber inzwischen ist es natürlich so, dass ich langsam dem Ruhestand entgegengehe und deswegen natürlich auch das etwas reduziert tue oder die Zahl der Mitarbeiter. Aber die, die da sind, sind unglaublich aktiv noch. Und wir machen immer noch super tolle neue Daten. Aber man sieht eben, dass Wissenschaft heutzutage zumindest in diesen Grundlagenbereichen der Naturwissenschaft, dass die zum einen eine gigantische Ausstattung braucht in unseren Bereichen. Also räumlich und auch gerätemäßig. Hightechgeschichten erfordert. Aber eben wirklich viel Manpower und das ist in Bochum halt wirklich eine fast optimale Umgebung. Es gibt eben die tolle Ausstattung, es gibt unglaublich aktive Studierende, die sich dafür interessieren.
Und es gibt eben auch die Stellen, die man sowohl entweder über Drittmitteln oder von der Universität bekommt, um so Riechforschung auf weltweit höchstem Niveau zu betreiben. Und nur so kamen diese Erfolge eigentlich zustande der letzten Jahrzehnte.
Ja und in dem Bereich ist ja auch noch eine Menge Bewegung. Wie man jetzt gerade an dem jüngst verliehenen Nobelpreis gesehen hat für die Kryomikroskopie.
Ja also wir brauchen natürlich zwar keine Kryomikroskopie, aber wir brauchen natürlich hochauflösende Mikroskopie zum Teil, um eben die Zellen auch zu sehen, an denen wir arbeiten. Und damit auch Reaktionen der Zellen anschauen zu können. Aber es gab ja auch vor, auch schon einige Jahre her wieder, den Nobelpreis für die Erforschung der Riechrezeptoren, also der Sensoren, mit denen wir Düfte wahrnehmen können. Aber wir hoffen ja immer, dass die Daten, die wir im Moment gerade machen, dass die vielleicht doch noch ausreichen, nicht vielleicht um einen Nobelpreis zu kriegen, wäre natürlich noch schöner, aber um eben ähnliche Gewichtung zu haben, wie die Sensoren selber, dass man eben auch entdeckt, dass die Sensoren nicht nur für die Nase, sondern eigentlich für unseren ganzen Körper von hoher Bedeutung sind. Und das ist ja eigentlich das zentrale Thema im Moment bei uns.
Bevor wir den Düften noch weiter auf die Spur kommen, würde mich natürlich nochmal interessieren, wie Sie zur Wissenschaft gekommen sind. Sind Sie schon so als kleines Kind mit dem Wunsch in diesen Bereich zu gehen groß geworden oder waren Sie eher ein Quereinsteiger?
Nein also Wissenschaft weiß ich nicht genau. Aber zumindest die Natur und die Biologie war etwas, was mich von jung an begeistert hat. Also als Kind musste ich immer, wenn ich abends nach Hause kam, erst mal meine Hosentaschen alle umdrehen, bevor ich überhaupt in die Wohnung reindurfte, weil irgendwelche Schnecken, Käfer, Würmer oder sonst was da drin steckten und ich habe also dann immer die habe Jugendzeit in irgendwelchen alten Kiesgruben und Tümpeln verbracht, um irgendwelche Viecher zu fangen. Also die Liebe zu Tier und Natur war immer schon in mir drin. Und ich hatte mir eigentlich von Jugend an nichts anderes vorstellen können, als in diesem Bereich zu arbeiten. Und als ich dann eben nach dem Abitur überlegte, was ich tun sollte, dann ging es eben darum. Die Medizin war spannend, fand ich sehr spannend in der Zeit natürlich auch und dachte mir, da könnte ich vielleicht in die Richtung gehen und das verbinden.
Von welcher Zeit reden wir jetzt?
Abiturzeit heißt so 68er Jahre. Und das heißt ich habe lange überlegt, ob ich das in Richtung Medizin machen soll. Der Notenschnitt war okay, aber ich habe dann mal ein Praktikum im Krankenhaus zuerst machen müssen und dann war ich in diesen Krankenzimmern. Und ich muss sagen, das hat wieder was mit riechen zu tun. Also da war dann dieser Geruch in diesen Zimmern und in dieser Klinik so intensiv für ich und auch unangenehm, dass ich gedacht habe, nein also das kann ich auf die Dauer eigentlich nicht aushalten. Und habe dann also doch entschieden, ich mache lieber Biologie und Chemie zuerst mal und das ist ja dann auch meine zweite Leidenschaft geworden. Und habe dann dieses Studium tatsächlich in München angefangen. Biologie und Chemie parallel gleichzeitig und beides dann auch mit dem Staatsexamen abgeschlossen.
Wobei man eben sagen muss, 68er Jahre das heißt man hat natürlich zuerst mal mehr auf der Straße verbracht und ich war also dann schon der klassische 68er, der dann auch durchaus mal ein Semester damit verbracht hat.
Erst mal die Revolution einleiten.
Die Revolution zu beginnen. Ja natürlich, das war von der Schule aus plötzlich eine völlig andere Welt. Wobei ich sagen muss, ich war weg immer kein guter Schüler. Also ich kann allen, die zuhören, und irgendwie denken, in der Schule muss man irgendwie super gut sein, um später Professor zu werden, also die kann ich beruhigen, man kann es auch ohne das. Im Gegenteil die Lehrer haben immer gesagt, mein Gott der soll doch lieber vielleicht zu einer Sparkasse gehen oder so, da ist er vielleicht besser aufgehoben als mit Abitur. Aber irgendwie als es mich dann interessiert hat das ganze Thema, da hat sich das völlig geändert die Welt. Und plötzlich habe ich dann auch Spaß am Lernen und an den Arbeiten und an den Dingen gefunden. Und habe also dann natürlich am Schluss doch noch ein relativ gutes Abitur gemacht, wie gesagt. Aber vorher war es eigentlich echt Katastrophe. Und dann die Münchner Zeit hat einen dann sehr geprägt, weil dann da wirklich die Professoren waren in der Biologie, die noch von Frisch und Konrad Lorentz, also Nobelpreisträgern, Autrum, das waren so die Urgesteine der deutschen Biologie.
Und die hatte ich dann als Hochschullehrer und das prägt einen dann doch enorm. Auch in der Chemie, da gab es dann also Butenandt und Carlsson, das waren Leute, die eben schon an Düften gearbeitet haben, auch Nobelpreise dann bekommen haben. Und das war eine unglaublich stimulieren Atmosphäre. Und ich hatte dann die Gelegenheit, weil Konrad Lorentz dann mal in einer Vorlesung fragte, gibt es denn irgendjemanden, der sich für Schmetterlinge interessiert? Weil er hatte ja sein Institut in Seewiesen gehabt, da zwischen Starnberger See und Ammersee in in Bayern. Und sein berühmtes Institut, wo er natürlich an seinen Gänsen gearbeitet hat vor allem natürlich und das Verhalten studiert hat und da gab es eben auch einen berühmtem Menschen, einen Professor Schneider. Der war sozusagen damals die Koryphäe, die sich mit Riechen bei Insekten beschäftigte weltweit.
Und da wurde vorher gerade auch vom chemischen Institut in München vom Butenandt entdeckt, dass es so Pheromone gibt, also Lockstoffe bei Schmetterlingen, die verwendet werden, um eben Männchen und Weibchen zusammenzuführen. Und dieser Professor Schneider und Lorenz haben sich für diese Dinge interessiert und kannten aber diese Schmetterlinge, die da rumflogen in Seewiesen, nicht. Und ich habe in der Zeit Schmetterlinge gesammelt und war also jede Nacht immer auf dem Dach oben gesessen, um die Nachtfalter zu sammeln und tagsüber mit irgendwelchen Netz rumgerannt, um die Schmetterlinge einzufangen. Die gab es damals zum Glück noch im Vergleich zu heute. Das ist ja ein trauriges Schicksal dieser Tiere muss man sagen, wenn man sieht, dass 75% der Schmetterlinge in den letzten 10 Jahren ausgestorben sind und abgenommen haben.
Da sieht man, was wir anrichten hier. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja ich kenne mich da aus und dann kam ich eben nach Seewiesen und habe auch ein Zimmer gekriegt und durfte dann als Student mit meinem kleinen VW immer hin und her fahren und dort immer eben am Wochenende die Falter bestimmen, die die während der Woche untersucht haben. Die haben also während der Woche die Falter gefangen da in Seewiesen. Haben sie in so kleine Plastikschachteln reingetan, haben die nummeriert und haben gesagt, an der Nummer 17 haben wir geschaut wie der riechen kann der Falter. Und ich musste dann sagen, dieser Falte ist eine Goldeule oder eine Silbereule oder irgendwas.
Sie waren so ein wandelndes Bestimmungsbuch?
Ich war ein wandelndes Bestimmungsbuch genau. So verbrachte ich aber ganz viel Zeit in Seewiesen, fand das faszinierend, diesen Riechforschern und Forschern überhaupt, auch Konrad Lorentz, bei der Arbeit zuzuschauen.
Seewiesen?
Seewiesen ist dieses Max-Planck-Institut für Verhaltensforschung, das eben wie gesagt dadurch berühmt wurde, dass Konrad Lorentz dort seine bahnbrechenden Experimente gemacht hat. Und dieser Kontakt mit den Wissenschaftlern dort und natürlich auch diese Atmosphäre und diese ganzen Technologien und was da alles gemacht wurde, da habe ich dann auch meine Examensarbeit geschrieben in Seewiesen, eben über Riechen bei Schmetterlingen. Und das hat mich dann so fasziniert, dass ich gedacht habe, Mensch das ist ein tolles Gebiet, man kennt noch ganz wenig, hat ganz wenig Informationen drüber und das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen da mal weiterzumachen. Weil als ich dann Biologie und Chemie abgeschlossen hatte mit dem Staatsexamen am Ende, da war natürlich die Frage, was mach ich denn jetzt? Und dann stellte sich eben für mich der Scheideweg, bleibe ich in der Biologie oder versuche ich doch wieder in meinem Urwunsch der Medizin zu arbeiten, zurückzukommen?
Und da kam eben dann ein Angebot von einem Professor Dudel, der damals in Heidelberg war und ein Mediziner war, dass er nach München kommt und dort an der technischen Universität in München ein völlig neues Institut für Physiologie aufbaut und Studenten suchte. Ich hatte eigentlich schon ehrlich gesagt in Regensburg zugesagt, nach Regensburg zu gehen und dort eine Doktorarbeit zu machen an Collembolen, das sind so kleine Springschwänze. Wenn jemand so einen Blumentopf hat und er schaut mal in die Erde rein, dann hüpfen da so kleine weiße Tiere oft rum. Das sind übrigens auch die Tiere, die uns wenn wir mal tot sind alle auffuttern. Also wenn man jetzt später einen Sarg aufgemacht hat in der Pathologie oder in der Gerichtsmedizin, dann ist der Mensch überdeckt von diesen kleinen Springschwänzen, die durch alle Ritzen durchkommen, weil sie so winzig sind und eben auch da uns verspeisen können. Und diese Springschwänze da wusste man gar nicht wie die riechen können. Die haben natürlich auch einen Geruchssinn, so kleine Antennen.
Und ursprünglich wollte ich mal das Riechen bei Collembolen machen da in Regensburg. Aber da kam eben Josef Dudel nach München und sagte, also ich suche einen Doktoranden, kommen Sie doch zu mir. Da habe ich gesagt, prima dann bleibe ich in München und mache bei ihm Doktorarbeit und studiere nebenzu, wenn es irgendwie geht, eben noch Medizin. Das war dann so eine Art Traum von mir, das zu verbinden. Biologische Doktorarbeit, die ich bei ihm machen konnte, offiziell bei Professor Autrum, aber dann eben bei ihm ausgelagert in dem Institut und eben noch Medizinstudium nebenzu. Ja und das habe ich dann auch so gemacht und dann habe ich da also drei Jahre Doktorarbeit gemacht, was jetzt eigentlich nicht direkt was mit Riechen zu tun hatte, sondern mit Flusskrebsen. Also diese Hummer und Flusskrebse, das waren die Haustiere von Herrn Dudel. Und der studierte sozusagen die Funktion zwischen Nerven und Muskeln, die Interaktion anhand dieser Flusskrebse.
Weil die waren gut zu präparieren und das System, diese Nerv-Muskel-Interaktion und -Leitung, die waren ähnlich wie beim Menschen, hat man damals jedenfalls gedacht. Und drum hat er das als Modellsystem genommen. Und dann hat wir es also über Flusskrebse im Institut und da man auch da nichts über Riechen von Flusskrebsen, wie finden die denn ihre Nahrung im Wasser, wusste, habe ich dann nur gefragt, ob ich denn nebenbei neben diesen Nerv-Muskel-Geschichten vielleicht auch das Riechen anschauen kann, weil mich das faszinierte. Und dann habe ich also tatsächlich meine Doktorarbeit eigentlich über das Riechen bei Flusskrebsen gemacht, nebenzu, neben den anderen Arbeiten, die wir da gemacht haben an dem Institut. Und gefunden, dass die Flusskrebse so kleine Antennen haben. Und an diesen Antennen, wenn die dann im Wasser sind, können sie also sehr genau detektieren, wo gibt es Nahrungsquellen?
Die fressen ja Gras, die fressen aber auch tote Fische. Also die haben dann Sensoren für toten Fisch und für Gras und so. Haben wir dann zum ersten Mal auch gezeigt, dass Flusskrebse auch mit ihren Beinen riechen können. Das heißt wenn die rumlaufen, dann treten die auf einen toten Fisch und so wie wir mit dem Finger dann in die Tomatensuppe reingehen könnten und dann können die riechen. Wir können das nicht, wir würden uns die Finger verbrennen, aber die können dann detektieren, welcher Duft da ist. Und das war dann die Doktorarbeit in der Biologie. Und dann ging es über den Hummer weiter. Wie riecht der Hummer, das ist auch ganz schön, weil dann konnten wir immer die riesigen Hummer essen und mussten nur die kleinen Antennen oben wegmachen, der Rest war dann zur freien Verfügung. Seitdem mag ich keine Hummer mehr, weil es die in großen Mengen gab. Aber natürlich in der Medizin war es jetzt nicht gerade das prickelnde Thema jetzt, wie riecht der Krebs und der Hummer?
Und dann ging es schon eher Richtung Mäuse dann natürlich auch. Ich hatte immer noch meine Vorliebe für Schmetterlinge nicht verloren, die ich ja in Seewiesen eingepflanzt bekommen habe. Wir haben dann auch noch das Riechen bei Schmetterlingen weitergemacht. Also wie findet so ein Nachtfalter, wenn es völlig dunkel ist, so ein Männchen, wie findet der sein Weibchen, dass da irgendwo im Gras oder im Wald sitzt. Und das war eben damals noch relativ unbekannt. Und es gab den Seidenspinner den chinesischen. Von dem wurde eben gefunden, dass das Weibchen Stoffe abgibt, also Pheromone, also Lockstoffe, um dem Männchen zu sagen wo es ist. Dafür gab es eben auch den Nobelpreis in der Zeit. Aber wie die deutschen Nachtfalter, die da rumflogen, wie die das machen, das wusste man nicht. Dann habe ich mich also mit diesem Thema noch nebenzu beschäftigt, also wie machen die das?
Ganz ähnlich, haben auch riesige Antennen, mit denen die Männchen nach Duftmolekülen schauen, die die Weibchen eben abgeben, spezielle Moleküle und die sie dann sozusagen zu den Frauen da hinführen. Immer der Nase nach quasi fliegen die Männchen dann. Wobei dann eben auch klar war, dass jeder dieser Schmetterlingsarten einen eigenen Lockduft haben muss, damit natürlich nicht der falsche Mann angelockt wird. Weil dann kommt er dahin und es ist gar nicht seine Frau, sondern das gehört zu einer ganz anderen Art. Drum hat jede Insektenform ihren eigenen Lockduft entwickelt. Also ein unglaublich kompliziertes System. Tausende von verschiedenen kleinen Variationen führen dazu, dass jede Art anders riecht oder das Weibchen einen anderen Duft abgibt. Und das war eben auch ein Teil der Arbeit, die ich dann gemacht habe bei Herrn Dudel in der Physiologie. Er war wirklich großzügig zu mir muss ich sagen, dass man in der Medizin solche dinge machen konnte. Und habe nebenzu Medizin studiert und das dann auch fertig gemacht.
Habe dann auch mal eine Zeit lang eine Praxis sogar gemacht, ich habe überlegt sogar in die Praxis zu gehen für zwei Jahre halt eine Praxis mal für Naturheilverfahren. Weil mich das auch noch brennend interessiert hat, gibt es denn da außer dieser Hardcore-Wissenschaft vielleicht so etwas wie Akupunktur und Homöopathie, was vielleicht sogar irgendeine Grundlage hat eine physiologische? Habe dann also die Ausbildung noch gemacht, um mich einfach ein bisschen breiter auszubilden. Und dazu noch Philosophie studiert und bis zum Bacheloriat sozusagen, weil ich sagte, du musst noch so einen anderen Schwerpunkt kriegen und nicht nur diese ganze naturwissenschaftliche Seite. Also wie denkt man auch anders vielleicht über die Welt. Ja und das war dann. Aber dann ging es eben doch eher über die Maus zum Menschen. Das Riechen faszinierte mich immer mehr. Ich habe dann noch eine Doktorarbeit in der Medizin gemacht anschließend natürlich, als mein Medizinstudium fertig war.
Da ging es dann schon um allgemeine Sensorik, also wie nehmen Tiere Temperaturen wahr? Chemische Reize und Temperaturen zusammen. Das wurde dann später in Bochum nochmal ein Schwerpunkt hier auch. Wir wissen ja, dass oft Temperatur und Chemie zusammenhängt. Also dass manche Stoffe, Minze, Menthol, wenn man die riecht, dann wird es einem kalt und wenn man auf eine Peperoni beißt, wird es einem heiß. So was gibt es also auch schon bei Tieren. Und solche Dinge haben wir dann studiert. Also diese Temperatur- und Chemiezusammenhänge. Sind das die gleichen Sensoren, die sowas machen? Und es ist tatsächlich so, also es gibt Sensoren, die sind für beides zuständig, Chemie und Temperatur. Und deswegen ist es klar, wenn ich die Chemie dann mit chemischen Stoffen diesen Sensor reize, dass der dann gleichzeitig auch eine Temperatur auslöst, eine Temperaturempfindung auslöst. Ja das war dann meine medizinische Doktorarbeit. Und dann habe ich mich dort habilitiert bei Herrn Dudel in der Physiologie.
Und eben dann nochmal eine physiologische Promotion gemacht, das gab es damals noch in München. Dass man dann in Physiologie noch eine Arbeit schreiben konnte. Und das war dann schon eine Arbeit, die generell um gesamte Duftempfindung bei Mensch und Tier ging. Und ja dann war eben die Frage, wie geht es weiter, wo kommt man unter dann mit diesen Themen? Und wir hatten eben in München neben dieser ja Riechforschung, die ich halt immer so nebenbei als Hobby betrieben habe, damals etwas ganz bahnbrechendes entdeckt bei Herrn Dudel und damit wurden wir auch eigentlich weltberühmt. Es ist uns nämlich zum ersten Mal gelungen damals in dem Institut, den Strom durch einen einzelnen Ionenkanal, durch einen Kanal in der Zellmembran zu messen, der nur ganz kurz aufmacht.
Zu dieser Zeit gab es zwei deutsche berühmte Forscher, Erwin Neher und Bert Sakmann, die beide Nobelpreise erhalten haben in den Jahren dafür, dass sie eine Technik entwickelt haben in der Zellmembran, die es in jeder Zellmembran des Menschen gibt, nämlich kleine Proteine, Kanalproteine zu detektieren und den Strom durch diese Kanalproteine zu messen. Also das sind wie so Lego-Bausteine, so wo 4-5 Bausteine eine Röhre bilden und diese Röhre kann auf und zu gehen. Kann durch bestimmte chemische Reize oder mechanische Reize kann diese Röhre auf und zu gemacht werden. Und wenn sie auf ist, dann fließt durch diese Röhre in die Zellen ein Strom, ein messbarer Strom. Und das war damals völlig unbekannt, dass es so was gibt. Und man dachte immer, die Zellmembran die bricht einfach auf und es gibt ein Leck und dann fließt dann was rein.
Aber die beiden Deutschen haben dann tatsächlich eine neue Technik entwickelt, nennt sich Patch-Clamp-Technik. Also eine Methode, die mit einer feinen Pipette setzt man sich über diese Kanäle. Das ist so ähnlich wie wenn der Ausguss verstopft ist, dann gibt es ja diesen Stößel da, das ist so ein Holzstab, wo unten so ein Gummi dran ist. Und so ähnlich sieht diese Pipette aus. Also man setzt so eine Pipette wie so einen Gummi über diese Zellmembran und macht die ganz dicht dann. So dass also wenn man einen Strom in dieser Pipette messen kann, man sicher sein kann, dass der unbedingt nur durch diese Löcher in der Membran geht und nicht irgendwie außen rum fließen kann. Das war die große Entdeckung von Erwin Neo und Bert Sackmann. Aber sie konnten eben diese Kanäle nur in einem permanent offenen Zustand messen. Also da musste der Kanal immer offen sein und dann fließt da so viel Strom durch, dass sie den sehen konnten. Und wir haben damals eine völlig neue Technik entwickelt. Nennt sich ein schnelles Applikationssystem.
Das heißt wir konnten dann Stoffe, die diese Kanäle öffnen, das sind so wichtige Botenstoffe, die wir beim Menschen auch im Gehirn haben, wie Serotonin oder Glutamat oder Acetylcholin. Also das sind Botenstoffe, die menschliche Zellen abgeben und bei der anderen Zelle dann so einen Kanal öffnen. Und diese Botenstoffe konnten wir innerhalb von einer tausendstel Sekunde auf eine Zelle applizieren und wieder wegnehmen. So dass wir also für eine tausendstel Sekunde sehen konnten, geht der Kanal auf oder nicht. Und wenn man ihn wieder wegnimmt, geht er wieder zu. Also wir konnten sozusagen das Schaltverhalten dieser Kanäle zeigen, aber bei der Gelegenheit haben wir etwas faszinierendes gefunden. Dass wenn man nämlich so einen Botenstoff für längere Zeit auf den Kanal gibt, für eine Minute oder Sekunde oder 10 Sekunden, dass es Kanäle gibt, die nur einmal aufmachen für eine tausendstel Sekunde oder zwei und dann wieder zumachen und nie mehr aufmachen.
Und das waren Kanäle, die vorher von den Nobelpreisträgern nie gesehen werden konnten, weil die immer nur diese Kanäle im dauerhaft aktivierten Zustand angeschaut haben. Und diese Kanäle, die so schnell und ganz kurz nur mal aufmachen, wenn sie ein Botenstoffmolekül sehen und wieder zu und obwohl das Botenstoffmolekül da ist weiterhin, nicht mehr aufmachen. Man nennt das also Adaptation, also Gewöhnung sozusagen. Diese Kanäle konnten wir nun zum ersten Mal zeigen überhaupt in der Welt. Und die sind eigentlich die entscheidenden für viele Gehirnprozesse, für die Nerv-Muskel-Interaktionen, da sind alle diese schnellen inaktivierenden Kanäle, die wurden früher gar nicht gesehen und die konnte man jetzt erstmals analysieren. Und das war wirklich bahnbrechende Arbeit in dem Labor von Herrn Dudel. Und damit wurden wir dann sehr bekannt und berühmt und das hat mir natürlich sehr geholfen bei meinen Versuchen, dann jetzt irgendwo eine Professur zu bekommen.
Weil es glaube ich keine besseren Forschungsbedingungen gibt als hier. Das ist einfach grandios. Und wenn man sieht, dass das Ruhrgebiet auch, wenn man hier rausschaut, einfach auch sehr sehr schöne Ecken hat und sehr schön sein kann und die Leute prima sind, also dann glaube ich nach einigen Jahren überlegt man sich, ob man hier überhaupt wieder weggeht.
Was macht denn die Forschungsbedingungen hier an der Universität so gut?
Also der Hauptgrund ist glaube ich, dass damals, als die Uni gebaut wurde, da wurde richtig geklotzt und nicht gekleckert. Das heißt also die Gebäude sind, wie man sieht, riesig, die Lehrstühle sind gigantisch groß. Ich habe glaube ich 1500 m², also eine ganze Etage ist ein Lehrstuhl. Damit kann man richtig viele Menschen Wissenschaftler beschäftigen, Studenten beschäftigen. Es gibt ganz viele Studenten, also 45.000 glaube ich. Das ist so die 3./4.-größte Uni Deutschlands in Bochum. Hat inzwischen natürlich auch einen exzellenten Ruf. Gehört auch zu den 10-15 Topuniversitäten in Deutschland. Und eben die Grundausstattung, die feste Grundausstattung, also sprich die Zahl der nichtwissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter, um die geht es ja auch immer. Also technische Assistenten, Sekretariat und so weiter, das ist hier sehr sehr gut. Und die anderen Stellen, die haben wir dann eben eingeworben durch Drittmittel, so dass wie gesagt zum Teil 50-60 Mitarbeiter hier beschäftigt werden konnten.
Und eben auch durch die schönen großen Räume konnte man auch sehr große Geräte aufstellen und man konnte nun wirklich in Bochum, ich glaube das gibt es in keiner Uni in Deutschland, diese Riechforschung sozusagen vom Molekül bis zur Wahrnehmung betreiben. Also man konnte von der Genetik, von der Biochemie, von der Molekularbiologie die Sensorenzellen, Rezeptoren isolieren und die dann untersuchen bis hin zum lebenden Menschen. Und mit den Kliniken zusammen die Tests machen. Also optimale Forschungsbedingungen einfach.
Sie haben ganz am Anfang gesagt, ich bin da hingekommen und es roch nicht gut. Waren Sie denn von Anfang an schon immer so ein olfaktorischer Mensch? Oder war das jetzt nur so daher gesagt?
Nein ich glaube ich habe von Anfang an als Kind schon auf Düfte geachtet und Düfte waren mir wichtig. Ich weiß nicht, es ist ja oft so anerzogen. Also meine Eltern hatten eine Lebensmittelgroßhandlung. Da haben wir auch gewohnt. Diese Lebensmittelgroßhandlung heißt, wir haben so was wie Edeka. Aber in unserem Wohnhaus war das große Lager, wo dann die Lastwagen die ganzen Lebensmittel abgeholt haben und wir haben im ersten Stock gewohnt und unten in dem Keller waren die ganzen Lebensmittel gelagert. Und die wurden dann in Bayern da überall rumgefahren dann in die kleinen Geschäfte. Und das heißt, wenn ich von der Wohnung runterging, dann kam ich in dieses große Lebensmittellager und in den Keller und da lagerte einfach alles was so das Herz begehrt und was man so gut riechen kann. Von Schokolade über, damals waren die Lebensmittel ja nicht vakuumverpackt, das war ja 1950 oder so was 1955 in der Zeit.
Da gab es die also noch offen in großen Kanistern und sonst was. Sowohl die Fische und die Eier und den Essig und alles wurde da abgefüllt. Ich war sozusagen von einer olfaktorischen Welt schon umgeben. Ich weiß nur, ich kenne eine Geschichte von meinem Großvater, es ging immer drum, dass ich natürlich, als ich so 3-4 Jahre alt war, war die Diskussion, ich soll doch endlich mal in den Gartengarten kommen. Einzelkind muss doch mal mit anderen zusammenkommen, in einen Kindergarten. Und dann hat also meine Mutter und mein Großvater an die Hand genommen, um mich da in Illertissen, wo ich geboren bin, sehr schöne Stadt im Allgäu, um mich dort eben in den Kindergarten zu bringen von diesen Schulschwestern. Und sie erzählen mir ganz offen, nachher haben sie mir erzählt, ich bin da also mit den beiden in den Kindergarten rein, da waren ganz viele Kinder drin und die haben da gespielt und so und ich bin da rein und habe nur zweimal gerochen und habe gesagt, hier stinkt es mir zu arg, hier geh ich wieder.
Und habe mich also von der Hand losgerissen und bin weggerannt und von da an war ich nicht mehr willig und bereit, in diesen Kindergarten zu gehen. Dann hat mich mein Großvater weiter versorgt und betüddelt und das war dann auch deutlich glaube ich die bessere Wahl. Weil wir dann ganz viel zusammen gemacht haben und rumgefahren sind in Illertissen. Also von daher war ich schon einfach immer so ein bisschen duftmäßig geprägt. Natürlich auch durch diese ganzen Düfte, die man da in diesen Tümpeln und überall hatte. Hat das dann gerochen. Und die Kiesgrube war direkt neben dem Haus, wo wir gewohnt haben oder in der Nähe vom Haus. Und unser Nachbar hatte irgendwie Ziegen und Tiere und da gab es auch einen Misthaufen. Darum sage ich immer, also mein Heimatgeruch ist eigentlich eher so Kiesgrube, Mist und alte Tümpel. Also da muss ich sagen, da unterscheide ich mich doch von andren Leuten. Die also diese Gerüche immer ablehnen. Also für mich ist das eher Heimatgeruch.
Das ist ja auch eine Frage der Gewöhnung. Weil wenn man nur in der Stadt großgeworden ist, dann empfindet man das natürlich als fremd bzw. hat vielleicht auch einfach nicht so das Training mitbekommen. Das kann ja auch helfen, vielleicht diese Riechsinne entsprechend auszubilden. Ich weiß nicht, beim Schmecken gibt es ja so Superschmecker, Leute mit besonders vielen Geschmacksknospen oder besonders gut ausgebildeten Geschmacksknospen. Gibt es so was auch beim Riechen und sind Sie einer?
Ich bin eigentlich muss ich sagen kein Superriecher. Ich habe keine Supernase, ich bedauere das manchmal. Also ich nehme viele Düfte wahr, die andere Leute nicht wahrnehmen, weil ich mir persönlich angewöhnt habe, sozusagen nicht nur mit offenen Augen, sondern mit offener Nase durch die Welt zu gehen. Das kann ich auch jedem, der jetzt zuhört nur empfehlen. Also man kann sich das antrainieren und man kann also wirklich damit eine Duftwelt bewusst wahrnehmen, obwohl man vielleicht gar nicht so ein Superriecher ist. Die andere Leute nicht wahrnehmen. Weil sie einfach keine Aufmerksamkeit darauf richten. Also wenn ich in ein Zimmer reingehe, dann rieche ich mich zuerst mal um, bevor ich mich umschaue. Das ist eine Angewohnheit, die kann man haben. Ein Hund wird es immer so machen, der wird erst mal schnüffeln, bevor er schaut, wie sieht es da aus. Oder wenn ich einem Menschen begegne, dann versuche ich auch einen Duft von ihm zu erhaschen. Oder diese Küsschen-Küsschen-Geschichten da. Die einen machen es nur, da hat man das Gefühl, das ist eine reine Formsache, dass sie einem da die Küsse geben.
Das aber der einzelne Sensor bei jedem Menschen etwas anders gebaut ist. Der wird ja genetisch bestimmt und der ist ein bisschen anders. Also der Vanillesensor, der Vanillin wahrnehmen kann, der ist bei jedem Menschen, den wir untersucht haben, etwas verändert. Und aufgrund dieser Veränderung kann er so verändert sein, dass er Vanillin in ganz unglaublich empfindlichen Konzentrationen wahrnehmen kann oder ganz schlecht. Also wenn man ins Detail geht, dann sieht man, dass jeder Mensch für jeden einzelnen Duft ein Superriecher sein kann oder ein schlechter Riecher. Dasselbe gilt für den Geschmack übrigens auch, da ist es auch so. Und dasselbe finden wir also für Riechen tatsächlich auch. Da fällt es nur nicht so auf, weil ich natürlich nie Einzeldüfte rieche, sondern immer nur Kaffeemischungen oder Parfümmischungen und da weiß ich natürlich nicht, ob ich das eine oder andere Molekül besser oder schlechter wahrnehme. Aber eigentlich heißt das, auch jeder Duft, den wir Menschen riechen, im Gruden genommen jeder Mensch anders riecht.
Also wenn ich jetzt ein Parfüm nehme oder einen Kaffee Ihnen anbiete, dann weiß ich eigentlich nicht, wenn ich ehrlich bin, wie Sie den Kaffee wahrnehmen. Und ich bin mir nach unseren Daten dabei 100% sicher, dass Sie den Kaffee nicht genauso riechen wie ich. Weil meine Kaffeesensoren, die darauf ansprechen, doch alle ein bisschen eine Veränderung haben gegenüber Ihren. Und darum gibt es den Gesamteindruck eben doch etwas unterschiedlich.
Also über Geschmack lässt sich nicht streiten, über Riechen eigentlich auch nicht?
Auch nicht, ganz genauso ist es ja.
1985 gab es ein neues Buch auf dem Markt „Das Parfüm“. Ist Ihnen sicherlich bekannt. Patrick Süskind. Ein Welterfolg, ein unglaublicher literarischer Erfolg. Von vielen glaube ich auch so als eine der wichtigeren Werke gehandelt der Weltliteratur. Übrigens auch sein einziger Roman, bemerkenswert. Die Geschichte eines Mannes mit einem unheimlich ausgeprägten Geruchssinn. Und daraus entspinnt sich dann so eine fantastische Reise durch das Paris der – ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, zu welcher Zeit das jetzt genau spielt. 1800, 1700 irgendwie so etwas. Haben Sie sicherlich gelesen.
Ja klar. Ich habe es geliebt und immer noch. Ich denke immer noch, das ist eines der faszinierendsten Bücher, die je geschrieben wurde. Da sieht man, dass man Riechleuten doch immer ein bisschen Unrecht tut in der Gesellschaft. Es verdient eigentlich längst den Nobelpreis. Weil es ist das erste Buch in der Geschichte der Menschheit von jemandem, der ein Buch aus Sicht – auch schon wieder der falsche Ausdruck – aus Sicht der Nase schreibt. Da muss man erst mal drauf kommen. Alle anderen beschreiben das was man sieht, die ganzen Bücher. Aber er beschreibt das was man riecht, das hat noch nie jemand gemacht. Und das kann auch nie wieder jemand so machen. Weil es ist jetzt einmal gemacht worden und das gibt es nur einmalig. Also eigentlich denke ich, allein diese Idee ist so gigantisch und man sieht schon, dass es sein einziges Buch war, er wusste genau, das ist etwas was unwiederbringlich einmalig ist. Also das hätte wirklich schon längst einen Nobelpreis verdient. Ob es literarisch jetzt ganz hochwertig ist, wenn eben auch Sänger den Nobelpreis kriegen können der Literatur, dann könnte schon längst dieses Buch den kriegen.
Allein für diese Idee, das so zu machen. Und man muss auch sagen, er hat eben sehr sorgfältig recherchiert. Er hat viele Dinge auch aus wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten, Habitilationsschriften aus dem Französischen übernommen und dort auch die Daten hergeholt dafür. Also die Geschichte ist, wenn man da jetzt als Geruchsforscher draufschaut, gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, wie sie immer klingt. Und gut das andere Beispiel ist auch, dass ich immer denke, dass auch den anderen, die mit Düften arbeiten, immer Unrecht getan wird. Warum sind Parfümeure oder Sterneköche warum sind die nicht unter Künstler eingeordnet? Warum kennen wir nur Maler und Musiker als Künstler? Das sind für mich mindestens die gleichen Wertigkeiten, was die künstlerischen Fähigkeiten anbelangt. Wenn ein begnadeter Parfümeur einen Duft macht, den noch nie eine Menschennase gerochen hat, den noch nie irgendjemand gemacht hat.
Dann mischt der eben 100 verschiedene Stoffe zusammen, um diesen großartigen Duft zu machen. Also ein Maler mischt halt Farben zusammen und ein Musiker Töne, das ist doch genau das gleiche. Oder ein 3-Sterne-Koch, der macht irgendein Gericht, noch nie ein Mensch ist auf die Idee gekommen, dieses Gericht zu machen. Riecht und schmeckt völlig anders als alles was bisher da war. Warum sind das keine Künstler? Die werden einfach nicht in dieser Kategorie anerkannt. Finde ich wahnsinnig schade und kämpfe immer auch in unserer Akademie, wo ja auch Künstler, dafür, dass die endlich mal zu ihrem Credit kommen, den sie eigentlich kriegen sollten. Und genauso ist das mit Süßkind auch. Also ich denke das Buch war fantastisch und hat die Welt der Düfte natürlich sehr geprägt und mir auch persönlich in meinem Wunsch, dem Menschen klarzumachen, die Nase gibt es, die ist wichtig und Düfte sind etwas viel viel wichtigeres als wir bisher gedacht haben in unserem Leben. Also diesen Wunsch, das nach außen zu tragen und dem Menschen zu vermitteln, das hat mir sehr sehr geholfen.
Ja das Visuelle und sicherlich auch das Akustische ist halt bei unseren Sinneswahrnehmungen kulturell auch dominant. Also nur Blinde haben da sozusagen zunächst einmal eine andere Einschränkung, die andere Prioritäten liefert. Aber für uns ist das Visuelle wichtig, weil natürlich der Augensinn ich würde mal sagen der nützlichste ist von allen. Das kann man jetzt natürlich auch nochmal debattieren. Aber ohne Frage ist es dominant. Wie Sie schon sagten, Maler, visuelles, Fernsehen etc., all das, Filmkunst spielt natürlich eine große Rolle. Wenn man jetzt das wegnimmt und es gibt ja zum Beispiel dieses schöne Experiment Dunkelrestaurants, wo man hingeht. Alles ist dunkel, um sich sozusagen die Welt mal anders einzuprägen. Finde ich interessant, weil man ja da nicht durch einen akustischen Parcours geht, was man ja auch machen könnte. Sondern man geht ja eigentlich durch so einen Geschmacks- und Geruchsparcours.
Es gibt ja immer so diese Zeichnungen, wo so einzelne Körperteile so groß gemalt werden wie der Anteil an der Wahrnehmung der Welt ist. Wo man dann auf einmal riesige Hände bekommt, weil man natürlich in den Fingern so stark fühlt. Aber auch die Nase wird auf einmal groß. Gehen Sie so durch die Welt? Ist das sozusagen eine andere Wahrnehmungspriorität, die man sich selber verleihen kann?
Ja mit Sicherheit. Also ich denke, dass die Duftwelt eben eine unsichtbare Welt ist, die uns umgibt überall, also wo wir hier jetzt sitzen. Das sieht ja alles wie Luft aus, die man nicht sieht. Das ist voller natürlich Luftmoleküle, sprich Sauerstoff und Stickstoff natürlich, die wir brauchen zum Atmen, das ist natürlich die Luft hier im Raum. Aber sie ist auch voller Duftmoleküle. Also wenn man die jetzt sichtbar machen könnte hier in einem Raum, dann würde man sehen, dass dieser ganze Raum voll ist mit kleinen rumschwirrenden Duftmolekülen wie Staubkörner. Und die sehe ich nicht, atme sie aber genauso ein wie Sauerstoff und Stickstoff. Und mit jedem Atemzug kommt diese Information, genau wie das was ich jetzt sehe oder was ich jetzt höre, kommt mit jedem Atemzug in mein Gehirn und informiert mein Gehirn.
Das kann ich nicht abschalten. 24 Stunden am Tag. Solange wir atmen riechen wir, von erstem bis zum letzten Atemzug. Und alle zwei Sekunden melden die Riechzellen in meiner Nase meinem Gehirn, welche Duftmoleküle hier mich umgeben haben. Und es gibt keinen duftfreien Raum auf dieser Erde, das heißt es wird nie in meinem ganzen Leben jemals passieren, dass mit meinem Atemzug keine Duftmoleküle in die Nase kommen und keine Information ins Gehirn fließt.
Es gibt kein Duftvakuum?
Nein das gibt es nicht. Also einen duftfreien Raum herzustellen ist sagen wir technisch einer der sicher ganz großen Herausforderungen. Also man könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwo einen Filter einbauen in einen ganz bestimmten kleinen Raum, wo man jedes Duftmolekül, was herumschwirrt, rausfiltert. Aber das geht gar nicht, weil man selber gibt ja ständig Duftmoleküle ab, die riecht man ja auch. Also es wird nie eine Sekunde in meinem Leben geben, wo ich keine Information von der Nase ins Gehirn schicke. Ich kann die Augen zumachen und kann die Informationen vom visuellen System ausblenden, dass da nichts mehr fließt. Ich kann die Ohren zuhalten. Aber ich kann es nie schaffen zu verhindern, dass Informationen über Düfte in mein Gehirn gehen. Das wird zeitlebens so sein. Und diese Duftwelt, die in unser Gehirn fließt, die verändert unser Gehirn. Das sind ja elektrische Strompulse, die da reinlaufen.
Die werden von den Gehirnzellen verarbeitet. Und jede zwei Sekunden verändern die Duftmoleküle in der Luft mein Gehirn, die Gehirnstrukturen. Da gibt es Speicher, die da laufen, die das abspeichern. Da gibt es aber auch Plastizität, Lernprozesse, all diese Dinge werden automatisch, ohne dass ich das merke überhaupt, in meinem Gehirn durch diese Duftverarbeitung, Duftwahrnehmung permanent modifiziert und verändert. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass wir eben dem Geruchssinn etwas unrecht tun, weil wir immer denken, wir Menschen sind irgendwie keine guten Nasen mehr, keine Supernasen, sondern eher irgendwie so Mininasen oder Nasenzwerge sozusagen. Aber das stimmt eben überhaupt nicht. Wir merken es nur nicht. Das Optische und das Akustische da sind wir eben mehr drauf trainiert und ausgerichtet mit unserer Aufmerksamkeit von Jugend an. Aber das könnte man auch genauso ändern.
Also man könnte tatsächlich, wenn wir Menschen von Jugend an, von Kindheit an das anders beigebracht bekommen. Also statt Singstunden oder Malstunden Riechstunden hätten, dann hätten wir glaube ich einen völlig anderen Zugang und dann könnten wir vielleicht auch mehr abschätzen, wie Tiere die Welt sehen. Sie sehen sie nicht eigentlich, sie riechen sie. Also ich glaube die Welt einer Katze, eines Hundes, hat einen völlig anderen Blick, einen anderen Hintergrund als die …
Eine andere Gewichtung.
Eine andere Gewichtung. Ja dann ist das Optische egal. Die riechen nur die Düfte, die um sie rum sind. Also man kann sich auch eine Welt nur in Düften vorstellen. Ich glaube wenn man blind und taub ist und nichts mehr hört, dann kann man sich an dieser Duftwelt orientieren. Und nimmt sie wahr, also das ist glaube ich eine ganz andere Wertigkeit.
Vielleicht auch schon navigieren wie ein Hund?
Natürlich. Also ich sage immer schon, warum soll den Lehrern nicht mal den Kindern sagen, versucht doch mal euren Schulweg einfach der Nase nach zu gehen. Ich glaube jeder kann sich, wenn er einen bestimmten Weg hat jeden Tag, den er geht, kann er mal versuchen die Augen zuzumachen und einfach der Nase nach zu folgen. Dann wird er feststellen, aha ich komme da vorn an die Ecke, da weiß ich, da steht immer ein blühender Strauch, den kann ich riechen. Wenn ich dann ein Stückchen weitergehe, dann kommt eine Tankstelle, die kann ich riechen und dann biege ich um eine Ecke rum, da ist eine Pommesbude. Also eigentlich kann man genau wie Tiere auch sich einen Duftweg einprägen und navigieren, einfach entsprechend solchen Duftmarken.
Müsste man sich aber auch akustisch abschirmen, weil das natürlich auch extrem präsent wäre.
Klar, die Akustik spielt natürlich auch eine Rolle natürlich. Aber man könnte einfach die Düfte nehmen, um sich zu orientieren und zu navigieren auch natürlich. So wie Tiere das tun. Wenn ein Hund …
Duftlabyrinth sozusagen?
Ja ganz genau, einer Duftspur folgen. Das kann man auch. Also man kann ja im Garten, wenn man Spaß hat, kann man das mal ausprobieren. Also im Garten zum Beispiel mal eine Schokoladenspur legen da durch das Gras und dann eben den Ehemann oder die Frau oder die Kinder verblinden, eine Brille aufsetzen und dann am Boden kriechend die Schokoladenspur verfolgen lassen. Dann wird man feststellen, das ist tatsächlich möglich. Also ich kann nach dem Duft im Gras die Schokoladenspur verfolgen. Wie ein Hund das auch kann. Der wird ja auch die Spuren des Fasans verfolgen.
Was ist denn jetzt genau ein Duft und was bedeutet es? Oder wie muss man sich den Vorgang des Riechens vorstellen?
Also alles was duftet, jeder Gegenstand, alles was eben einen Duft hat, Blume, Fisch, was auch immer, gibt kleine chemische Moleküle in die Luft ab. Also ein Duft ist eigentlich eine entweder einzelne Sorte oder in der Regel eine gemischte Sorte von kleinen chemischen Molekülen. Die so klein sein müssen, also wissenschaftlich gesehen ein Molekulargewicht. Man kann ja auch das Gewicht von solchen kleinen Molekülen, wie ein Vanillinmolekül zum Beispiel oder ein Moschusmolekül, das ist ja ein Molekül, das kann man auch wiegen. Also es sollte unter 300 Dalton haben. Also dieses Molekulargewicht haben. Dann sind die so klein die Moleküle, dass sie schweben können. Also größere Moleküle fallen runter und liegen am Boden, die Kleinen schwirren wie Staubkörner in der Luft herum.
Und diese kleinen chemischen Moleküle, da gibt es unglaublich viele verschiedene. Jeder, der in der Chemie mal tätig war, weiß das: es gibt Alkoholmoleküle und Aldehyde und Ketone und Amine, also unglaublich viele chemische Gruppen, aber auch innerhalb dieser Gruppen ganz viele Untersorgen von Molekülen. Und diese kleinen Moleküle schwirren in der Luft und die nehme ich eben mit jedem Atemzug in die Nase auf. Und in der obersten Etage unserer Nase da sitzt nur die Riechschleimhaut. Die eist ungefähr, wenn wir beide Nasen zusammennimmt, ungefähr so groß wie ein Eurostück. Und in dieser Riechschleimhaut befinden sich nun Riechzellen. Also das sind spezialisierte vorgelagerte Gehirnzellen, sagt man da. Die haben einen Nervenfortsatz, der ins Gehirn hineinreicht. Also durch den Schädelknochen hindurch geht von jeder Riechzelle ein Nervenfortsatz in das menschliche Gehirn hinein.
Man kann es allerdings auch umgekehrt sagen. Also es kommt ein Nervenfortsatz aus dem Gehirn heraus durch den Schädelknochen und bildet außen diese kleine Riechzelle. Und über diese Riechzellen strömt nun die Luft, die wir einatmen, hinweg.
Das heißt die Verbindung zum Gehirn ist unmittelbar?
Unmittelbar. Es gibt eine Leiterbahn. Also wir haben 30 Millionen Riechzellen in etwa beim Menschen in dieser Riechschleimhaut, in dem kleinen Stückchen, dieser kleinen Fläche und jede Riechzelle hat ihren eigenen kleinen Nervenfaden, der ins Gehirn geht. Also wir haben 30 Millionen kleine Nervenfäden, die von der Nase ins Gehirn ziehen. Und es wird aus der Atemluft, die wir aufnehmen, jetzt nicht die ganze Atemluft über die Riechzellen geleitet. Sondern es wird eigentlich in der obersten Etage, wo die Riechschleimhaut ist, da ist so eine kleine Hautfalte, die ist so ganz dünn und faltig und die hat nur einen kleinen Spalt. Und durch diesen Spalt wird aus der Atemluft jeweils bei jedem Atemzug eine kleine Probe entnommen. Zwei Prozent ungefähr der Luft. Und diese zwei Prozent werden dann über die Riechzellen geleitet. Und enthält natürlich die Duftmischung, die wir mit der Luft einatmen, die Duftmoleküle.
Und nun wissen wir, dass es beim Menschen die 30 Millionen Riechzellen gibt und aber jede Riechzelle ein Spezialist ist. Also jede Riechzelle stellt nur einen Typ von Sensor her. Das ist fantastisch. Wir wissen nicht genau warum. Also Sensoren heißt Rezeptoren wissenschaftlich gesagt. Also jede Riechzelle produziert eine ganz bestimmten Rezeptorsorte.
Also ist quasi nur für einen bestimmten Duft da?
Für einen bestimmten Duft geeignet ja. Diese Rezeptoren sind wie Schlösser und das Duftmolekül ist der Schlüssel. Also jede Riechzelle macht nur einen Typ von Schloss, davon natürlich ganz viele, also hunderttausende. Also die Vanillezelle macht nur Vanillerezeptoren, wo das Vanillemolekül als Schlüssel passt. Und diese Riechrezeptoren werden von unseren Genen gemacht. Das heißt in unserem Genom gibt es für jeden dieser Riechrezeptoren ein eigenes Gen und das wird angeschaltet und dann produziert es eben diese Riechrezeptoren. Warum jetzt eine Riechzelle nur ein Gen von diesen Rezeptoren anschaltet, das weiß man bis heute noch nicht so richtig. Also wir haben insgesamt 350 verschiedene Gene für die Rezeptoren und damit auch 350 verschiedene Rezeptoren können wir machen.
Das heißt eigentlich können wir auch nur 350 verschiedene Gerüche unterscheiden?
Einzelgerüche.
Einzelne Komponenten von Gerüchen.
Einzelne Komponenten. Aber die Mischung macht halt die unendliche Vielfalt ja. Und das heißt also jede Riechzelle schaltet nur eines der Gene an und kann also damit nur eine ganz bestimmte Duftmolekülsorte erkennen. Die eine kann Moschus erkennen, die andere Vanille, die dritte Buttersäuremoleküle und so weiter. Wobei diese Schlösser jetzt nicht so präzise sind wie so ein Schweizer Tresor, wo es nur diesen einen Schlüssel gibt.
Passt halt meistens richtig und kann aber auch mal schiefgehen?
Nein, es ist wie so eine Schließanlage. Das heißt diese Schlösser sind so eher alte Schlösser, wo man auch mal wenn der Schlüssel schon mal eine kleine Zacke weg hat, dann sperrt es immer noch auf. Das heißt es gibt schon verschiedene, man kann an so Duftmoleküle, wie das Vanillin zum Beispiel, das das Vanilleschloss aufsperrt, das Vanillemolekül kann schon kleine molekulare Veränderungen tragen und dann wird es immer noch das Vanilleschloss aufsperren. So dass man also da schon eine gewisse Vielfalt auch drin hat. Ja und jetzt wenn ich also Vanillinmoleküle, weil ich gerade irgendeinen Apfelkuchen mit Vanillepudding esse, dann sind da Vanillemoleküle in der Luft drin, die ich einatme und diese Vanillemoleküle würden jetzt also dann die Riechzelle, die die Vanilleschlösser trägt an ihrer Oberfläche, diese Schlösser würden sie aufsperren. Und was man jetzt nun weiß ist, dass mit dieser Aktivierung des Schlüssels in dem Vanilleschloss wird in der Riechzelle eine ganz komplexe biochemische Maschinerie angeschaltet.
Eine Signalverstärkungskaskade wie wir sagen, Maschinerie. Das heißt dieser Vanillerezeptor induziert in der Riechzelle, dass biochemische Prozesse ablaufen und eine bestimmte Sorte von Molekülen, die heißen CAMP, Cyclisches Adenosinmonophosphat, die nennt man zweiter Botenstoff, dass diese CAMP-Moleküle in dieser Riechzelle in riesigen Mengen hergestellt werden, etwa 2000 Stück pro Rezeptor. Und jedes dieser CAMP-Moleküle kann jetzt in den Riechzellen einen Kanal öffnen. Hatten wir vorher schon mal erzählt. Es gibt in der Zellmembran Kanäle, also Eiweiße, die, wenn sie geöffnet sind, Strom leiten. Also ich kann mit einem Vanillemolekül 2000 Kanäle öffnen gleichzeitig. Und damit eine richtig große Strommenge in die Zelle treiben. Da fließt Strom durch jeden einzelnen Kanal, natürlich nur winzige Mengen von Strom.
Aber wenn natürlich 1000 oder 2000 Kanäle aufgehen, dann fließt schon eine ganze Menge Strom rein. Und deswegen sind wir eben auch so empfindlich. Drum können wenige Duftmoleküle schon in einer Zelle so viel Strom erzeugen, dass dieser Strom, der da erzeugt wird so groß ist, dass er über den Nervenfortsatz bis ins Gehirn fließt. Also wenn eine bestimmte Menge an Strom erreicht wird in der Zelle durch das Öffnen dieser Kanäle, dann eine Schwelle überschritten wird, dann produziert die Schwelle sozusagen einen Superstrom, den man Aktionspotenzial nennt und der über den Nervenfortsatz ins Gehirn geleitet wird. Und das Gehirn informiert die Vanillezelle, ich Vanillezelle bin gerade von einem Duftmolekül getroffen worden. Und das ist also faszinierende Signalverstärkung. Und das noch faszinierendere, was das Riechen hat, was ich immer denke, und wo man auch gar nicht weiß, warum es so ist, ist, dass es im Gehirn des Menschen und bei Tieren in diesem Riechhirn, nennt man Bulbus olfactorius, Riechkolben, der direkt hinter der Nase liegt.
Also in diesem Riechkolben des Menschen oder von Tieren, selbst von Insekten wie Schmetterlingen, in diesem Riechkolben liegen nun lauter kleine Kugeln, kugelförmige Strukturen. Und wenn man diese kleinen kugelförmigen Strukturen zählt, dann korrelieren die mit der Zahl der Riechzelltypen in der Nase. Also wir Menschen haben 350 verschiedene Riechzelltypen, weil wir ja 350 von diesen Sensoren haben und wir haben 350 Kugeln. Irgendein Maikäfer hat 70 Riechzelltypen und hat 70 Kugeln in seinem Maikäfergehirn und eine Maus hat 1000 verschiedene Riechzelltypen, weil die sozusagen noch mehr Sensoren hat als wir und hat 1000 Kugeln. Und es ist tatsächlich nun gezeigt worden wissenschaftlich, dass in diesen kleinen Kugeln im Riechhirn alle Riechzellen, die den gleichen Duft wahrnehmen, also alle Vanillezellen, enden in der Vanillekugel.
Und alle Moschuszellen senden alle Moschuszellen in die Moschuskugel. Und alle Buttersäurezellen in die Buttersäurekugel. Also woher diese Nervenfortsätze wissen, die Vanillezelle, ich muss in der Vanillekugel enden, und mein Signal dorthin senden, das weiß man bis heute noch nicht so richtig. Das heißt also in diesem Riechhirn entsteht ein Aktivitätsabbild dessen, was auf dieser zellulären Ebene in der Nase passiert. Also wenn ich nur reines Vanillin rieche von einem Vanillepudding, dann wird nur die Vanillezelle in der Nase natürlich Strom produzieren und nur die Vanillekugel in unserem Riechhirn wird Strom bekommen. Und ich muss also jetzt in meinem Erinnerungs- und Gedächtniszentrum auswendig lernen, wenn diese eine Kugel, wo die Vanillezellen enden, wenn die Strom bekommt, dann ist das Vanille.
Und sie kriegt mehr Strom, umso mehr Zellen …
Umso mehr Moleküle, umso mehr Vanillemoleküle, umso mehr Strom kriegt sie und umso intensiver ist es dann auch. Aber so einfach ist es normal nicht. Normal ist es so, dass ich Düfte rieche, die Mischungen sind. Also ich kann Vanille-Apfel-Kuchen essen, dann habe ich noch die Apfelmoleküle dabei. Und die Apfelmoleküle aktivieren natürlich auch wieder Apfelzellen. Jetzt grob gesagt. So dass ich also dann im Riechhirn jetzt eine Mischung aus Vanille- und Apfelzellen haben, und das können dann nicht eine Kugel sein, sondern werden dann vielleicht vom Vanille-Apfel, werden dann vielleicht von den 350 Kugeln, die wir haben, werden dann vielleicht 50 aktiviert, weil in dem Apfel so viele verschiedene Duftstoffe drin sind. Da kommt noch der Kuchen dazu und so weiter. Und diese 50 Kugeln, die ich bei Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen aktiviere, die muss ich jetzt nun auswendig lernen. Da muss ich also sagen, das ist Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen, ich sehe ja was ich esse oder jemand sagt, das ist Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen.
Und dann muss ich die Kugelkombination lernen, den Namen lernen, das wird alles im Erinnerungszentrum abgespeichert und gleichzeitig und das ist das wichtigste beim Riechen, gehen diese Informationen auch in das limbische System, das Emotions- und Gefühlszentrum. Und dort werden dann Gefühle ausgelöst durch diesen Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen. In der Regel natürlich angenehm, Wohlgefühl.
Es sei denn etwas ist verdorben.
Es sei denn es ist verdorben oder stinkt, dann ist es natürlich unangenehm. Und das wird gleichzeitig auch noch mit meinem Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen-Muster abgespeichert im Gehirn. Also ich habe jetzt ein komplexes Paket geschnürt, wenn ich Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen rieche, ich speichere jetzt in meinem Gedächtniszentrum das Wort „Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen“ ab, weil ich das gerade gelernt habe, dass das so heißt das Ding. Das komplizierte Muster mit 50 Kugeln und noch die Emotion, die ich jetzt habe, also Wohlgefühl. Und wenn ich jetzt dieses Muster, dieses 50-Kugel-Muster wieder hervorrufe, künftig, indem ich den Duft wieder rieche, dann wird das Paket wieder aufgeschnürt. Dann sehe ich wieder die Bilde vom Apfel-Vanille-Kuchen vor mir. Ich weiß den Namen wieder und die Emotion kommt auch wieder gleichzeitig mit hervor. Ich fühle mich plötzlich wieder wohl oder es ist irgendwie angenehm, weil ich den Duft rieche.
Ist das denn alles erlernt?
Alles erlernt ja. Jeder Duft, den wir zum ersten Mal riechen, wird unter diesen Aspekten abgespeichert und damit erlernt.
Gilt das auch dann sozusagen für das was man als eklig oder gefährlich empfindet? Oder sind da bestimmte Düfte schon soweit vorabgespeichert, dass auch ein Baby weiß?
Es ist nicht bekannt, dass etwas angeboren ist. Also auch ein Baby muss lernen, was eklig ist. Auch ein Baby muss lernen, was gefährlich ist. Also das ist nichts was genetisch fixiert ist, im Gegensatz zu den Geschmacksrezeptoren. Bitter, süß, sauer, salzig, das ist genetisch fixiert. Kinder, die nie irgendwas bitteres hatten, nach der ersten Sekunde auf der Welt werden sie auf bitter unangenehm reagieren und auf süß angenehm. Das ist fest verdrahtet. Aber Duft ist alles erlernt. Und das Lernen beginnt, wie wir schon wissen, bereits im Mutterleib. Das heißt also wir können diesen Duft wahrnehmen, den ich gerade beschrieben habe. Die kann nicht nur in der Luft stattfinden, die kann auch schon im Mutterleib als Embryo stattfinden im Fruchtwasser. Also wir riechen sowieso unter Wasser. Da denken die meisten Leute nicht dran, weil wir immer denken, die Düfte sind ja in der Luft. Aber natürlich auch die Zellen sind auch alle unter Wasser. Das heißt alle Düfte, die wir riechen, müssen erst mal durch die Wasserschicht durch, durch das Wasser im Schleim.
Eine Zelle würde ja in der Luft sofort austrocknen, dann würde die gar nicht funktionsfähig sein. Also wir riechen eh unter Wasser. Aber man kann eben auch als Embryo riechen. So 26.-27. Schwangerschaftswoche, da funktioniert das Riechsystem schon perfekt. Ich kann nicht nur Düfte wahrnehmen, ich speichere auch die Emotionen dazu ab, die Informationen von der Mutter kommend. Also Embryonen riechen mit der Mutter mit und nehmen sogar deren Emotionen mit auf.
Sie riechen dasselbe was die Mutter riecht?
Genau. Also wenn jetzt eine Mutter irgendeine ganz, also Franzosen haben es mit Anisgeruch gemacht und es gibt viele andere Tests auch mit anderen Düften, dass wenn ich in der Schwangerschaft einen ganz bestimmten Duft wahrnehme, auch eine bestimmte Emotion vielleicht dabei habe, weil ich sie gerade ganz toll finde, das riecht dann der Embryo mit und er speichert auch die Emotionen schon damit ab. Das heißt also man kann sagen, dass Kinder, die auf die Welt kommen, die kommen schon mit Duftvorlieben auf die Welt, die sie von ihrer Mutter erlernt haben. Also der Embryo ist sozusagen schon das erste Klassenzimmer, das Duftlernen beginnt schon da.
Aber wie kommt denn das Duftmolekül dann im Embryo an dieselbe Stelle?
Das Duftmolekül wird eben über die Atmung, da kommen wir wahrscheinlich später noch drauf zu sprechen, das wissen wir inzwischen wissenschaftlich, dass Duftmoleküle natürlich in unsere Körper gelangen, nicht nur können, sondern auch tun. Also wenn ich Duftmoleküle einatme, ich kann sie in die Haut einreiben, ich kann sie esse natürlich auch. Wenn ich eine Orange esse, dann gehen ja die ganzen Duftmoleküle in meinen Körper und wir wissen, die werden danach nicht wieder ausgeschieden. Also meine Exkremente riechen ja dann nicht nach Orange oder so etwas. Das bleibt alles in unserem Körper zurück. Das heißt also, wir wissen, dass durch die Atmung, durch die Haut, durch die Nahrung Duftmoleküle in unser Blut gelangen können und die kann man dort auch analysieren. Also man kann zeigen, dass wenn jemand in einem bestimmten Raum ist mit einem bestimmten Duft und den einatmet, dann kann ich die Duftmoleküle in seinem Blut nachweisen und kann ihm auch beweisen, dass er in dem Raum war.
Aber die Emotion der Mutter ist doch dann zeitversetzt.
Die Emotion der Mutter ist relativ parallel. Also wenn die jetzt einen Apfelkuchen wieder mal isst mit Vanille, um mal beim Beispiel zu bleiben, oder ein Anisplätzchen ist und sie hat da ein Wohlgefühl dabei, dann setzt sie natürlich Wohlfühlhormone frei. Die werden auch im Blut mit ausgeschieden. Und offensichtlich beeinflussen die auch den Embryo, dass er dann auch über diese Wohlfühlhormone diesen Duft mit dem Wohlfühlen verbindet. Und man kann also, auch wenn die Mutter ein ganz extremes Erlebnis mit Düften hat, dass sie also sagen wir mal zu einem Unfall kommt, wo jetzt gerade jemand verbrennt und sie hat diesen extremen Brandgeruch und diese emotionale wahnsinnige Bedrückung und Angst und so etwas, dann wird auch dieser Duft bei dem Embryo, wenn er auf die Welt kommt schon, genau diese Emotion auslösen.
Also extrem starke Angst und alles. Also man kann bei Mensch und Tier eigentlich zeigen, bis zu vier Jahre nach der Geburt, dass man immer noch auf diesen Duft reagiert, den man eigentlich nur aus dem Mutterlieb her kennt.
Das heißt auch viele Ängste sind unter Umständen zumindest riechbegleitend? Also wenn man sich bestimmter Ängste entledigen möchte therapeutisch, weil sie überhand genommen haben, dann ist ein Teil davon unter Umständen auch über das Riechen zu therapieren?
Also Angsttherapie mit Düften ist ja inzwischen relativ modern geworden. Also man kann es eben über solche Lernprozesse machen, aber man kann es natürlich auch über Konditionierung machen. Also was eben auch natürlich gut geht ist, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Spinnenphobie habe und ich versuche jetzt tagsüber mit allen möglichen psychologischen Verfahren diese Spinnenphobie zu reduzieren oder ich habe Angst vor Bienen und ich gebe während dieser therapeutischen Sitzung zum Beispiel einen Duft in den Raum, dann verknüpfe ich natürlich diesen Duft mit dieser Therapie und kann durch den Duft allein schon die Therapie verstärken. Es gibt da auch schon Überlegungen, das im Schlaf zu tun. Wie gesagt, wir riechen 24 am Tag.
Wir riechen die ganze Nacht mit jedem Atemzug, riechen wir und nehmen die Düfte war. Und ich könnte jetzt also auch versuchen, im Schlaf mich zum Beispiel zu konditionieren. Und diesen Duft zu riechen und damit die Angsttherapie von tagsüber zum Beispiel zu repetieren. Ist auch wichtig, wie es im Schlafzimmer riecht. Also Schlafdüfte bestimmen auch unseren Schlaf, unsere Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz. Und zu Trauminhalten, wir haben viele Doktorarbeiten gemacht in München noch im Schlaflabor, um zu zeigen, dass das enorme Wirkung auch auf den Schlaf hat und auf die Trauminhalte, die Düfte im Schlafzimmer.
Parfüm kommt ja vom Wortstamm her sozusagen aus dem Rauch heraus. Wir hatten es ja schon angesprochen, Parfüme sind ein dickes Ding. Es gibt eine entsprechende Industrie und viele andere Anwendungen auch. Wie hat sich denn diese Kunst entwickelt und welche Bedeutung hat das für uns?
Ja es ist eigentlich ein uraltes Produkt, Parfüm. Es hieß ja früher durch den Rauch, das heißt also man hat früher natürlich immer versucht, über den Rauch, der ja nach oben aufsteigt, eben die Gottheiten, die irgendwie oben saßen im Himmel, zu erreichen. Und da gibt es schon alte griechische Theaterstücke, die darauf basieren, dass die Menschen eben über dieses Parfüm, über den Rauch, über Weihrauch oder über andere Räucherwerke eben die Götter gnädig stimmen. Und dass man zum Teil eben auch versucht, sozusagen Feinde der Götter versuchen sich dann zwischen die Götter und die Menschen zu setzen und den Rauch abzufangen, dass die dann nicht mehr zu den Göttern kommen können. Also wir haben diese Räucherwerke ja im alten Ägypten.
Und wir haben Parfümanwendungen auch schon 2000-3000 Jahre vor Christus, da findet man diesen Duft. Gerade was den Zugang zu den Gottheiten anbelangt, schon uralt. Wobei die Menschen sich dabei eigentlich nicht so beduftet haben, sondern es war immer so, dass das Parfüm, dieser Duft, den man genommen hat, ein Opferduft war für die Götter, es war etwas göttliches. Und es hat dann sehr lange gedauert, eigentlich bis nach Christus auf jeden Fall, in dieser Zeit Kleopatra und so die haben dann angefangen, sich selber auch zu beduften.
Aber beim Weihrauch ist das jetzt so vollkommen unbeabsichtigt, dass man eigentlich auch selber schon ein bisschen high wird von den Düften?
Genau, also man hat natürlich schon die Wirkung gewusst, dass wenn ich manchmal dem Gott so was darbringe, dass mir das selber dann auch irgendwie Wirkung erzeugt und guttut und high macht und ähnliches. Es wurde dann auch ziemlich schnell natürlich diese Düfte zum Symbol für bestimmte Götter. Also Weihrauch war ja immer so, dass der in der christlichen Kirche eine Rolle spielte und dass ja zum Teil auch die Christenverfolgungen darauf basierten, dass die Leute quasi dem Weihrauch abschwören mussten, weil der Weihrauch ein wichtiges Instrument war, um auch dem christlichen Gott zu huldigen. Aber Weihrauch ist natürlich auch insofern, da haben Sie natürlich recht, auch im Grunde genommen das erste Marketingprodukt gewesen, das so die Kirche erfunden hat oder die Gläubigen. Weil es ist schon klar, Weihrauch wurde also dann benutzt in bestimmten katholischen Kirchen für den christlichen Gott.
Und wer danach roch, der gab damit nach außen natürlich auch kund, ich glaube an diesen Gott. Wenn einer aus der Kirche kam und das ist ja heute noch so, der riecht einfach nach Weihrauch. Weil der Weihrauch, den man dort verwendet, der bleibt in den ganzen Kleidern hängen, und wenn man rausgeht, dann trägt man sozusagen dieses Markenzeichen der christlichen Kirche trägt man auch überall rum. Wir haben ja gerade den Kölner Dom beduftet vor einem Jahr, also diesen riesigen Kölner Dom, ein riesiges Duftevent gemacht und ich habe hier da schon diesen Weihrauchduft hier stehen, Weihrauch 2.0 verwendet. Das heißt also …
Darf ich mal riechen?
Ja, das ist also jetzt der neue moderne Weihrauchduft.
Aber da ist auch normal Weihrauch drin?
Es sind kleine Komponenten des Weihrauchs drin natürlich klar, erzeugt ja auch so einen gewissen Weihrauchduft. Es ist jetzt also kein Parfüm, sondern wir haben tatsächlich jetzt … das Domkapitel hat sich irgendwie gewundert, dass ja diese große Gamescom in Köln immer ist mit 200-300.000 Jugendlichen im Jahr und die gehen aber nicht so gern in den Kölner Dom. Und die haben da mal so rumgefragt, warum geht ihr denn nicht hin? Und da haben die gesagt, naja zum einen ist es ja so ein bisschen duster da drin und die Musik gefällt uns nicht so gut und vor allem es riecht so komisch da drin. So ein bisschen abgestanden und nach älteren Herrschaften und so.
Es riecht nach älteren Herrschaften.
Und da haben die gesagt, dann machen wir mal ein Event und machen mal eine Lasershow, dass mal ein anderes Licht reinkommt. Wir heuern irgendwie DJs an, die machen mal eine andere Musik und wir beduften den Dom jetzt noch. Und da kamen die dann auf mich zu und dann haben wir jetzt also in den letzten Jahren einen Weihrauch 2.0 Duft entwickelt. Also einen modernen Weihrauchduft, der sozusagen für die jungen Leute auch so angenehm riecht und den sie kennen aus ihren Parfüms und ihrer Umgebung. Und haben dann jede Nacht von 22 Uhr abends bis in der Früh um 2 Uhr haben wir dann dieses Event gemacht. Da wurde dann die Musik von den DJs vorgetragen. Es gab eine Lasershow, von so heiligen drei Königen, die wie Roboter waren. Und es wurden Duftschläuche, 100 Meter lange Duftschläuche von den Säulen gehängt, durch die dann eben der Duft Weihrauch 2.0 zur Musik und zu dem Event entlassen wurde. Und jeden Abend ab 22 Uhr war der Kölner Dom rammelvoll bis um 2 Uhr, es gab überhaupt nie einen freien Platz.
Also die haben immer nur so Massenabfertigung gemacht, 2000 rein, dann mussten die anderen wieder raus, um überhaupt die Leute durchzukriegen. Die Schlangen waren unendlich lang. Da sieht man eben, dass doch Duft auch ein Lockstoff ist.
Lag das jetzt an den DJs oder an den OJs, die da olfaktorisch Soundkulisse gemacht haben?
Ja alles zusammen. Es ist also ein sensorisches Event natürlich, aber der Duft war schon ganz wichtig, weil eben wie gesagt schon ein gewisses Problem war, dass die gesagt haben, es riecht irgendwie nicht so angenehm.
Aber was war denn jetzt in dem Geruch drin, dass das jetzt anders wirken soll?
Also es ist ein kleiner Anteil von Weihrauch natürlich, aber nicht dieses schwere, dieses starke, also jeder hat so einen Weihrauchduft in der Erinnerung, ja das ist so ein bisschen völlig benebelnd und so. Sondern es sind leichte flüchtige Komponenten im Weihrauch drin, das auch an Weihrauch erinnert natürlich, wenn man riecht. Es sind auch Stoffe drin wie Hedion, also Stoffe, von denn wir wissen, dass sie eine gewisse kommunikative Wirkung bei Menschen ausüben, frische Wirkung riecht man auch. Ein bisschen Bergamotte und solche Dinge, die also auch eine Frische reinbringen, eine Jugendlichkeit. Also es ist einfach eine moderner Aspekt von Weihrauch, eine moderne Ausführung von Weihrauchduft, der unglaublich gut ankam dann ja auch.
Modern heißt ja so ein bisschen, dass wir hier auch von Moden reden.
Genau.
Also dass Geruchspräferenzen sich über die Zeit ändern.
Tun sie auch natürlich klar. Also es gibt ein Parfüm, das man vor 100 Jahren, also Chanel No. 5 ist ja jetzt irgendwann in dem Alter. Also so wie es damals gerochen hat, würde man es heute nicht mehr verkaufen können. Das heißt Duftvorlieben ändern sich natürlich auch, sind einem Zeitgeist unterworfen. Wir sind natürlich einer Gewohnheit unterworfen. Wir riechen bestimmte Düfte an Mitmenschen, wir riechen sie in Parfümerien. Und so wie halt auch Kleider irgendwie sich ändern, also man läuft ja auch nicht mehr so rum wie vor 100 Jahren und so riecht man jetzt auch nicht mehr wie vor 100 Jahre. Also auch das Duftsystem hat natürlich eine Anpassung an Zeiten erlebt. Das ist natürlich reine Gewohnheit. Also da gibt es ja immer so Modedüfte, die man nimmt und die ändern sich ja auch permanent.
Es gibt ein paar traditionelle Düfte, die allerdings auch wenn man ganz ehrlich ist nur noch den Namen tragen von dem alten und auch nicht mehr genauso riechen wie damals. Also Chanel No. 5 riecht jetzt mit Sicherheit nicht mehr so wie damals, als es kreiert wurde.
Das heißt der Brand bleibt gleich, aber der Duft geht mit der Zeit?
Der Duft wird an die Zeit langsam angepasst natürlich ja.
Lebensmittel ja wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja natürlich Lebensmittel und alles. Es muss immer etwas … also sehr sehr vorsichtig natürlich, weil also da sind wir schon sehr empfindlich. Also auch bei Waschmittel, wenn Sie jetzt ein schönes Persil oder irgendeinen Duft haben oder von einem anderen Waschmittel, dann wollen Sie den schon haben. Und Sie müssen extrem vorsichtig sein, um da diese kleinen Veränderungen reinzukriegen, weil sonst sagen die Leute sofort, nein das ist nicht mehr das was ich kenne. Also insofern ist der Zeitgeist da, aber man muss sich manchmal zwangsweise anpassen, also wenn Sie Chanel No. 5 nehmen oder auch Waschmittel, es werden ja auch zunehmend Duftverwendungen verboten. Weil man stellt also fest, dass Eichenmoos oder bestimmte Düfte, die in der Parfümerie häufig verwendet wurden früher, dass die jetzt bestimmte negative Effekte haben auf den Menschen.
Allergien.
Allergien oder andere Dinge. Und da werden die tatsächlich verboten und dann dürfen die nicht mehr benutzt werden. Und deswegen müssen die sowieso ersetzt werden. Aber es ist auch ein Zeitgeist natürlich drin. Und der schwankt auch so ein bisschen. Also manchmal sind die Krawatten wieder breiter, dann sind sie wieder schmaler, dann ist das Revier wieder breiter und schmaler. Das ist ja auch so bei der Kleidung und so ist es bei den Düften auch. Zur Zeit kommen ganz frische Noten. Es ist dann ganz toll, wenn Sie Calvin Klein nehmen oder wenn Sie ja alles was Bergamotte und Zitrusnoten sind, wenn Sie diese Düfte nehmen, die waren eine Zeit lang ganz modern, und jetzt kommen wieder eher die schwereren Düfte und die animalischeren Düfte, die dann im Vordergrund stehen. Also die Parfüms müssen sich auch ein bisschen ändern, damit sie wieder neu verkaufen können. Sonst müssten die ja immer nur das gleiche verkaufen.
Ja. Sie sagten vorhin, der Weihrauch sei ja auch schon ein Marketinginstrument der Kirche gewesen. Weil man ja sozusagen mit diesem Geruch automatisch die Präsenz in der Kirche verbindet. Und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das dann schon als Suchtfaktor gelten kann, aber zumindest ist es ein Wiedererkennungswert. Ähnliches hat man ja auch in typischen Situationen, mag es dass man Dinge als muffig und unangenehm empfindet und dann diese Orte eher meidet. Andere Orte mögen einladender sein. Wie wird denn das … also ist das ein Ding, sozusagen Duft als Marketing?
Ja, also ich glaube die Industrie hat die letzten 20 Jahre doch zunehmend und in den letzten Jahren vielleicht sogar extrem stark wahrgenommen oder bemerkt, dass eine Duftmarke neben einer optischen Marke, die ja ein Produkt hat oder eine Firma hat, doch von einem unglaublichen Wert ist. Dass also Duftmarken, sprich dass eine Firma sich einen Duft gibt, dass ein Produkt beduftet wird, was eigentlich gar keinen Duft hat, um das geht es ja dann hauptsächlich. ich meine manche Dinge riechen ja von selber. Wenn ich jetzt Lederschuhe kaufe, Leder riecht von selber, da brauche ich jetzt keinen, da kann ich den Duft verstärken. Aber da brauche ich jetzt keine Duftmarke setzen. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein Handy bedufte, dann hat das ja an sich keinen Duft, das Plastik in dem Teil. Sondern da gebe ich in das Plastik halt dann Duftmoleküle rein oder bei, so dass das Plastik dann auch nach Duft riecht.
Das wird getan?
Ja so was gibt es jetzt natürlich. Alle Samsung Handys riechen jetzt nach Samsung und alle Adidas Schuhe riechen jetzt nach Adidas. Und alle Telekomshops in Deutschland riechen jetzt nach Telekom. Und alle Hilton Hotels riechen nach Hilton.
Und Kaufhäuser riechen nach wie vor nach allem möglichen in der ersten Etage.
Ja gut die normalen Düfte, die da natürlich auch eine Duftmarke sind. Aber man kann denen ja noch einen Zusatzduft geben.
Na ich finde diese olfaktorische Vergewaltigung, der man dann so ausgesetzt ist, wenn man in so ein Kaufhauseingänge reingeht, wo dann ja meistens sofort als erstes die Parfümabteilung ist. Ich habe noch nie verstanden, warum das jetzt unbedingt so sein muss, weil mich das eigentlich immer gleich wieder rausschickt. Aber was sind denn das dann für Gerüche? Also ich meine, wo das wahrscheinlich eine große Rolle spielt, wenn man sich in etwas befindet, also ein Auto zum Beispiel, man sagt ja auch, riecht nach neuem Auto.
Genau Neuwagenduft ist ja auch so was klassisches.
Das heißt Neuwagenduft ist eigentlich keine Folge aus Materialien nur, sondern das ist unter Umständen auch eine gezielte Herbeiführung eines bestimmten Geruchs, der frischer Neuwagenduft heißt?
Also in dem Fall natürlich eigentlich ursprünglich nicht. Denn ursprünglich ist ganz klar, wenn ich ein ganz neues Auto kriege, genau wenn ich einen neuen Schrank kaufe oder irgendwas, dass dieses Produkt nach den verwendeten Materialien duftet. Also so ein Auto hat halt innen drin so Klebstoffe, Plastik und dieses Zeug. Wenn man ehrlich ist, es wird eigentlich von kaum einem Menschen als ein angenehmer Duft beurteilt, der nicht gerade Erfahrungen mit Neuwagen hat. Also normal ist dieser Klebstoff-Plastik-Mischungsduft eines Neuwagens, wenn Sie jetzt irgendwelche Menschen fragen, die noch nie ein Auto gerochen haben, die sagen, das riecht eher nicht so dolle. Aber wenn Sie jetzt natürlich ein Jahr oder zwei auf ein Auto sparen und es kommt das neue Auto und Sie machen die Tür auf, sind in einem emotionalen Ausnahmezustand, dann ist doch ganz klar, dass dieser Duft, den Sie dann riechen, in Ihrem Gehirn unmittelbar mit einem extrem emotional positivem Gefühl abgespeichert wird, das Sie in diesem Moment haben und dass Sie mit diesem Duft natürlich dieses Gefühl wieder hervorholen können, wenn Sie ihn wieder riechen.
Und dann lernt das Gehirn, dass es gut ist.
Und da lernt das Gehirn, dass es positiv ist, sagen wir mal so. Und inzwischen kann man eben diesen Neuwagenduft natürlich auch synthetisch herstellen, wie eigentlich alle Düfte, die wir so kennen.
Gibt es das auch schon als Spray?
Ja klar, können Sie auch schon sprühen, können Sie als Neuwagenduft diese schrecklichen Tannenbäume da ins Auto hängen und all dieses schreckliche Zeug.
Das heißt bevor man seinen Gebrauchtwagen verkauft, holt man sich noch ein bisschen Neuwagenduftspray?
Genau, dann kriegen Sie sicher mehr dafür als vorher. Weil das immer natürlich … das ist ja ein Teil des Marketingkonzepts ja. Aber es ist auch etwas, wir wissen natürlich als Riechforscher, dass Dufterinnerungen viel stabiler im Gehirn abgespeichert werden als optische Erinnerungen. Es gibt viele Arbeiten, die zeigen, wenn Sie einen optischen Reiz mit einem Duft zusammen abspeichern, dann ist das ungefähr mindestens 10 mal länger, zum Teil auch 100 mal länger im Gehirn eingebrannt, dieses Branding, diese Duftmarke, als nur das optische Zeichen. Deswegen ist es natürlich besonders interessant für Firmen, frühzeitig Menschen mit einem Produkt und einem Duft zusammenzubringen. Weil dieser Duft dann, also Nivea-Duft kennt jeder und dass diese Duftmarke eben so eingebrannt ist. Und die lernt man vielleicht sogar schon im Mutterleib. Deswegen geht man so weit, dass man sagt, wer Zugang zu schwangeren Frauen hat, hat schon Zugang zum späteren Verbraucherverhalten.
Wenn Sie also da in einem schönen Auto sitzen, das einen ganz bestimmten Duft hat, und die Schwangere fühlt sich darin wohl und nimmt den Duft wahr und das Kind riecht mit, dann ist sicher später schon der Duft, den das Kind da wahrgenommen hat, schon ein angenehmer Duft. Wobei ja die Kinder auch den Duft der Mutter kennenlernen. Das ist zum Beispiel wenn die auf die Welt kommen, dann erkennen die schon ihre Mutter von dieser Embryonalzeit her, und wissen genau, wie ihre Mutter riecht. Und jede Mutter würde das Kind sofort an ihrem Duft erkennen, und unterscheiden können. Das wäre das leichteste für eine Mutter, bei Wetten, dass… aufzutreten, ich kenne mein Kind unter 100 raus. Aber auch umgekehrt, also die Kinder erkennen die Brust der eigenen Mutter wieder. Das macht manchmal sogar Schwierigkeiten bei Leihmüttern, dass sie überhaupt die Brust akzeptieren. Also das lernen wir alles schon im Mutterleib. Also auch solche Markendüfte lernen wir eigentlich schon. Und später dann auch.
Also ich denke, Duftmarketing macht unglaublich viel Sinn, drum haben alle Hotels inzwischen ihren eigenen Duft. Jedes Hilton auf der Welt riecht gleich, jedes Sheraton, alle Hotels, das heißt Sie kommen in so ein Hotel, riechen den schönen Duft, haben vielleicht ein schönes Wellnesswochenende. Wenn Sie diesen Duft dann wieder riechen beim Betreten des Hotels, haben Sie schon ein Wohlgefühl.
Oder zumindest einen Wiedererkennungswert.
Ein Wiedererkennungswert.
Weil Wohlgefühl ist ja, wie wir schon festgestellt haben, sehr individuelle Geschichte, kann ja auch sein, dass man so ein Hotel dann gar nicht riechen kann.
Genau, also wenn ein Hotel ganz schrecklich ist, dann kann man es auch nicht riechen. Dann kann man auch sagen, nein da will ich nicht rein. Also Sie können mit dem Duft sogar, da gibt es also inzwischen viele Studien, die zeigen, dass auch die Bewertung des Hotels auch von dem Duft dann abhängig ist. Also selbst ein schlechter Service an der Rezeption, eine eher schäbige Ausstattung im Hotel können Sie durch den Duft dramatisch in der Bewertung der Menschen verbessern. Also das ist schon ein Instrument, das heutzutage …
Da würde ich doch als Hotelbetreiber gleich mal in das teuerste Hotel reingehen und mal gucken wie die so riechen und dann einfach diesen Duft kopieren. Lässt sich das dann überhaupt einfach machen oder ist Duftkreation eher so eine One-Way-Street?
Nein es lässt sich schon machen. Ich meine Düfte lassen sich ja interessanterweise nicht patentieren, weil eben die Duftmoleküle … Also um etwas zu patentieren bedarf es einer optischen Darstellung. Also ich muss eine optische Darstellbarkeit haben, so entscheidet das europäische Patentamt, sonst kann ich nichts patentieren. Die chemische Formel allein ist nicht die optische … also wenn ich ein Vanillinmolekül male, dann ist das keine optische Darstellung des Vanillinduftes. Weil jeder Mensch es ja auch anders empfinden kann. Und deswegen kann man Düfte nicht patentieren, weil man sie nicht optisch darstellen kann, ein Parfüm. Deswegen kann man nur die Marke patentieren lassen, also ich kann den Namen patentieren, aber nicht die Zusammensetzung. Deswegen wird das ja auch nie offengelegt, was da drin ist. Weil es nicht patentierbar ist. Aber man kann natürlich heutzutage Düfte analysieren, über Gaschromatographen, über Massenspektrometrie kann ich eigentlich jeden Duft dieser Welt in seine kleinen molekularen Bestanteile zerlegen, aus denen diese Mischung besteht. Und kann den dann auch sogar nachbauen.
Also wenn ich jetzt so einen Hilton-Duft haben will, dann gehe ich einfach mal mit einem Kanister einmal an der Rezeption vorbei, mach den Deckel zu und …
Ganz so einfach ist es leider nicht. Also ein Parfümeur könnte, wenn er den Hilton-Duft riecht, eigentlich schon aufgrund seiner Nase die wichtigsten Bestandteile, aus denen dieser Hilton-Duft besteht, herausriechen und kann sagen, was da drin ist. Das können ja geschulte Nasen, da brauche ich gar keinen Gaschromatographen, da nehme ich einfach eine ganz geschulte Parfümeursnase, die kann dann schon einen groben Anhaltspunkt geben, wie es da drin riecht.
Wie so ein Musiker in so einen Song reinhört und sofort weiß, aus welchen Frequenzanteilen das besteht.
Genau. Also das ist fantastisch was Parfümeure eben können, aufgrund ihres Trainings. Also die trainieren ja jeden Tag 1-2 Stunden riechen und drum können die auch so gut riechen. Die haben die gleichen 350 Sensoren wie wir auch.
Die trainieren riechen?
Ja, also die meisten, wenn die in der Früh in die Firma kommen, dann versuchen sie schon mal eine Stunde lang Düfte zu riechen. Also die lassen sich Düfte geben aus ihrer Sammlung und riechen die und versuchen die zu identifizieren. Also man muss ja denken, so ein Duft, das Duftalphabet hat 350 Buchstaben. Sie haben 350 Sensoren zur Verfügung. Duftwörter, wie Mischungen aus Kaffeeduft, Bananenduft, Rosenduft oder so etwas, die besten aus 50, 100, 200 verschiedenen Duftstoffen, die also von den 350 Rezeptoren 100 aktivieren. Also so Duftwörter bestehen aus 100-150 Buchstaben. Und die müssen Sie auswendig lernen, um sie wieder zuerkennen. Also Duft riechen ist viel viel schwieriger, als Wörter zu lernen.
Und ist ja auch keine binäre Geschichte, sondern jeder Duft ist ja noch unterschiedlich stark.
Ja und jeder ist noch unterschiedlich stark. Also da kommt noch was anderes raus. Also es ist unglaublich kompliziert. Diese Kugeln, also a) müssen Sie die Kombinationen dieser Kugeln lernen und b) noch die Stärke, wie stark die aktiviert sind, jede einzelne Kugel. Und deswegen müssen sie so wahnsinnig viel trainiert. Sie müssen jeden Tag üben, üben, üben. Mein letztes Buch, das kleine Buch vom Riechen und Schmecken, da gibt es am Schluss, ein Drittel des Buches besteht nur aus Anleitung zum Dufttraining. Wie können Sie Ihre Nase trainieren, dass Sie diese ganzen komplizierten Duftmuster leichter lernen? Wie können Sie überhaupt Düfte, nicht die Duftleistung verbessern, sondern auch Ihr Duftvermögen im Alter zum Beispiel auch verlängern. Wir wissen, dass Riechen genauso abnimmt wie Sehen und Hören. Also man riecht auch schlechter im Alter. Dass jeder eine Brille braucht oder ein Hörgerät, da stört sich schon keiner mehr dran, aber dass man nicht mehr riechen kann, das glauben die meisten Menschen gar nicht.
Aber wenn man sie dann testet, dann sieht man es erst. Und dann sind sie oft ganz erschrocken. Da gibt es aber keine Hilfsmittel dafür. Da kann man nur durch Riechtraining, wie Parfümeure das machen, jeden Tag sich wirklich mindestens 2-3 mal am Tag 15 Minuten mit Riechen intensiv zu beschäftigen, damit kann man a) diesen Riechverlust hinauszögern und b) das Riechen trainieren und das Gehirn trainieren. Weil natürlich jeder Duft, den ich rieche, gleichzeitig auch meine Hirnplastizität verändert. Also insofern Parfümeure sind wirklich aufs Riechen angewiesen. Und dann können Sie eben einzelne Komponenten aus diesen Düften herausriechen. Halt wie ein Weinkenner vielleicht auch. Wenn er sehr viel riecht, dann kann er irgendein Brombeeraroma rausriechen, das ein normaler Bürger gar nicht riecht.
Für die Uni haben Sie dann auch schon mal Marketing gemacht, riecht es hier in diesen Räumen nach Wissenschaft?
Ja nach Wissen riecht es eigentlich, nach Knowledge. Der Duft des Wissens, den wir mal gemacht haben. Das heißt wir haben halt dann irgendwann zum 15. Geburtstag der Uni gesagt, dass wir ihr einen eigenen Duft schenken wollen. Wie man halt Menschen, denen man irgendwas verdankt, und die man gerne mag, denen schenkt man ja ein Parfüm und der Uni haben wir jetzt eben gesagt, wir machen euch ein eigenes Parfüm, dass ihr die erste Universität in der Welt seid. Noch keine andere Uni jemals kam auf die Idee, deswegen musste man schnell sein, der Uni einen eigenen Duft zu schenken.
Muss man immer warten, bis der Alkohol verflogen ist?
Das dauert ein bisschen. Und dann haben wir einen Duft kreiert.
Knowledge heißt er.
Der heißt Knowledge, das Wissen. Den gibt es auch überall, 30 Euro ein wunderbarer Duft. Bei Uni, Piper überall. Und diesen Duft, der ist eben auf die Uni Zugschnitten. Das heißt in einem bestimmten Kulturkreis haben Düfte eine bestimmte Bedeutung. Also wenn wir in unseren Kulturkreis gehen, hier in Deutschland, Europa, dann ist es doch so, dass der Großteil der Menschen zum Beispiel mit Orangenduft eine positive Konnotation hat, eine positive Abspeicherung hat, weil die meisten halt Orangen mögen und die kriegen sie zur Weihnachtszeit und dann ist das halt so. Vanille übrigens auch, ist häufig auch sehr positive besetzt. Und andere Düfte wie Fäkalien oder Schweißgeruch ist eben negativ besetzt, weil die Eltern uns immer sagen, als Kind hat man ja, wenn man auf die Welt kommt, eigentlich kein unangenehmes Gefühl, wenn man Schweiß riecht oder wenn man Fäkalien riecht, die spielen damit die Kinder.
Solange bis die Mutter oder Vater ihnen auf die Finger hauen und sagen, Junge, Mädel du hast hier ein Stinki gemacht, ein Kaka, oder du riechst ja nach Schweiß pfui Teufel jetzt wasch dich doch mal. Und das ist der Grund, warum wir das unangenehm finden. Wenn die sagen würden, ach das riecht ja wunderbar was du da gemacht hast oder dieser Schweißgeruch ist ja himmlisch heute wieder, dann würden wir eine völlig andere Einstellung dazu haben. Man kann das umerziehen, das ist eine reine Erziehungsgeschichte. Und ist eigentlich blöd, dass wir uns so erziehen. Weil natürlich genau diese Düfte, die der Mensch abgibt, das sind ja eigentlich Informationsdüfte, die wir abgeben. Das heißt wir geben ja über diese Exkremente, auch über den Urin, Düfte ab, die dem Mitmenschen im Grunde genommen auch was sagen könnten. Drum sind ja Tiere so an den Düften von den anderen interessiert.
Was sagen die Düfte denn?
Alles mögliche.
Was man isst oder nicht isst?
Was man isst. Sie könnten zum Beispiel einem sagen, ob man krank ist. Sie könnten einem sagen, ob man zum Beispiel Stoffe ausscheidet, die man nun genau in den Urin reintut, um dem Mitmenschen eine Botschaft zu geben. Das machen Hunde auch. Also da sind Düfte drin, die man zum Beispiel bei Angst abscheidet, oder die man abscheidet, wenn man läufig ist bei Hunden. Also da sind auch Informationsdüfte drin.
Aber die nehmen wir ja nicht so bewusst wahr.
Nein leider nicht. Also wenn Sie jetzt den Schweiß nehmen, ist ja etwas, wo wir eine komplexe Mischung abgeben von Düften. Das Schweißige, Ranzige, Fettige das sind die Buttersäuren, die sind gar nicht von uns, sondern das ist ein Mikrobiom, Mikroorganismen, unsere Körperoberfläche machen die. Die zerhacken die langkettigen Fettsäuren, die wir abscheiden und Talg in kleine, die dann in die Luft fliegen. Also das ist gar nicht von uns. Aber im Schweiß haben wir auch eine individuelle Duftmischung drin, die ein Parfüm, das jeder Mensch herstellt, das nur er macht. Es gibt keinen anderen Menschen, der das gleiche Parfüm herstellt wie er. Daran kann ein Hund eben jeden Menschen unterscheiden. Das ist auch im Schweiß drin, ein Wiedererkennungsduft, ein olfactory fingerprint nennt man das. Und wir geben auch Informationen, also Pheromone, chemische Signaldüfte in den Schweiß, um den Mitmenschen was mitzuteilen. Die muss man nicht unbedingt riechen können. Die können auf uns wirken, obwohl wir sie gar nicht riechen können.
Könnte denn ein solcher olfaktorischer Fingerabdruck so gut gemessen werden technisch, dass man ihn auch entsprechend unterscheiden kann? Also kann man sich einen Sensor vorstellen oder gibt es einen technischen Sensor, der Menschen am Geruch erkennt, während man irgendwo langgeht?
Es arbeiten Leute dran. Es ist glaube ich noch nicht perfektioniert. Also Hundenasen können es ohne Probleme. Und was natürlich Hundenasen können, das müsste man eigentlich auch technisch bewerkstelligen können. Also es arbeiten Leute dran, dass man auch Türschlösser macht, die auf Duft reagieren und nicht nur auf Fingerabdrücke oder Augen. Das gibt es ja schon. Also das wäre was. Normal nimmt man halt, also die Stasi hat ja jeden Menschen oder vielen DDR-Bürgern natürlich diesen Duft abgenommen, das in Gläser abgefüllt, die kann man ja heute noch sehen in den Museen. Und daran kann man die heute noch Wiedererkennen. Also wenn man das will über Hunde oder so was, kann man die heute noch in großen Menschenmengen finden lassen diesen Menschen, wenn die Hunde nur an dem Glas riechen. Also wir haben einen genetischen Fingerabdruck, wir haben einen eigenen Duft, der von unseren Genen gemacht wird. Das ist das was man weiß. Also unser Genom, vor allem die Gene des Immunsystems, die sind für den Duft zuständig.
Und da jeder Mensch eben eine andere Genotypisierung hat, das macht man ja bei Organtransplantationen, Blutspenden und so weiter, haben die auch unterschiedliche Düfte. Je ähnlicher zwei Menschen riechen, umso ähnlicher ist ihr Genom. Also ich kann meine Geschwister am Duft erkennen, weil sie so ähnlich riechen wie ich selber. Und was man halt weiß ist, aus dem Tierreich auch und beim Menschen im Übrigen auch, dass diese genetischen Informationen des persönlichen Duftes benutzt werden, um den richtigen Partner zu finden für die Fortpflanzung. Man will ja Inzucht vermeiden in der Evolution und um das zu vermeiden, können wir jetzt natürlich Genotypisierung machen als Menschen, wenn wir das wollen und können feststellen, dass es ähnliche Gene sind, das ist mein Bruder, auch wenn ich es nicht wüsste, weil ich nicht mit ihm aufgewachsen bin. Aber Tiere können das eben nicht und die benutzen nur diesen Körperduft für die Partnerwahl.
Und aber auch bei uns ist es so, dass auch Menschen, Frauen zum Beispiel, diesen Duft nehmen, um ihren Mann auszusuchen. Nämlich auch um einen auszusuchen, der möglichst unterschiedlich von ihnen selber riecht, um eine große Gendurchmischung zu kriegen. Weil das dann ein stabileres Immunsystem gibt, ein besseres, ein breiteres und eine größere Gesundheit garantiert. Also Menschenfrauen würden jetzt, wenn man ihnen 10 T-Shirts zum Riechen gibt, und sagt, welchen von den Männern, ohne dass der Mann drin steckt, willst du dich fortpflanzen? Dann würden die auch das T-Shirt wählen von dem Mann, der unterschiedlich zu ihnen selber riecht. Interessanterweise nicht ganz unterschiedlich, das ist auch schlecht. Und ganz ähnlich ist schlecht. So das Optimum ist so bei 75% genetischen Immunitätsunterschieden. Das ist der optimale Duft, den jemand haben muss, um von einer Frau dann am attraktivsten gefunden zu werden, wenn es um Fortpflanzung geht.
Und deswegen sind Parfüme auch so beliebt, weil man sozusagen meint, damit diese Wahl da streichen oder abändern zu können.
Kann man auch, kann man tatsächlich. Also man kann über Parfüms diesen eigenen Körperduft unterstützen und verstärken und damit intensivieren sozusagen. Und da gibt es auch Arbeiten inzwischen, wissenschaftlich anerkannte gute Arbeiten, die zeigen, dass tatsächlich über Parfüms so eine Potenzierung, Verstärkung des Körperduftes auch gemacht wird unbewusst beim Menschen. Also auch bei Frauen ist es so, dass sie ihren eigenen Körperduft dadurch verstärken, je nach Immunsystem. Es gibt sogar eine neue Forschungsarbeit, die zeigt, aus dem Max-Planck-Institut in Plön, die zeigt, dass die Töchter von Müttern, immer nur die Töchter, die den genetischen Hintergrund der Mutter haben – die könnten auch den vom Vater haben – die immunologisch den Hintergrund der Mutter haben, die benutzen später auch das Parfüm der Mutter weiter.
Die Töchter, die den Hintergrund vom Vater haben immunologisch, die suchen sich ein neues Parfüm, das zu ihrem genetischen Hintergrund passt. Also das machen wir alles unbewusst. Also das heißt die Evolution möchte natürlich zwei Dinge erreichen, eine hohe Fortpflanzungszahl, eine Quantität, vor allem aber auch eine Qualität. Dass die Nachkommen eben möglichst gesund sind. Und dafür hat sie eben feste Mechanismen entwickelt. Und da gehört eben so was dazu, dass sich über die genetische Passung das eben relativ gut kompensieren kann. Wobei man eben weiß, dass die Frauen ein viel höheres Risiko bei Schwangerschaften haben, die haben auch den viel höheren energetischen Einsatz, den sie bringen müssen bei Nachkommen. Die müssen das Kind austragen neuen Monate, oder dürfen, wie man sagt.
Aber sie müssen sehr viel mehr Energie investieren. Und deswegen sind die Frauen eigentlich im gesamten Tierreich und beim Menschen eigentlich die, die die Partner auswählen. Also die sind für die Qualität zuständig sozusagen. Die Männer sind eher für die Quantität zuständig, die versuchen sozusagen ihre Spermien überall zu verteilen. Für die Frauen ist es wichtig, den richtigen zu finden. Und da spielt eben der Duft eine ganz wichtige Rolle, weil eben die Genetik da dahintersteckt hinter dem Duft. Aber das ist auch in Achselschweiß mit drin. Dann gibt es noch Pheromone, die waschen wir auch mit ab, wenn wir uns abwischen. Wir wissen auch, dass wir Menschen tatsächlich Pheromone, also Signalstoffe, abgeben, um den Mitmenschen was mitzuteilen. Das sind diese Stoffe, die ich damals in meiner ersten Arbeit …
Mit den Schmetterlingen.
… Arbeit mit den Schmetterlingen. Es sind sechs Wahlpheromone, was die Schmetterlinge haben. Das heißt da gibt das Weibchen einen ganz speziellen Duft ab und die Männchen haben dafür die Antennen und erkennen den Duft und werden dann durch den Duft gezwungen, und das ist bei Pheromonen eben, das unterscheidet Pheromone von Düften, eigentlich zwei grundlegende Dinge. Erstens diese chemischen Signalkommunikation, Signaldüfte, Pheromondüfte. Die wirken nur innerhalb einer bestimmten Art. Also ein Pheromon, was eine bestimmte Nachtfalterart, eine Goldeulenweibchen produziert, der lockt nur Goldeulenmännchen an. Und bei anderen wirkt das gar nicht. Also eine Silbereule oder eine große Eule reagiert nicht drauf. Also nur innerhalb einer Art. Und zweitens Pheromone haben noch eine zweite wichtige Eigenschaft, sie sind nun nicht wie Düfte einer subjektiven Bewertung unterlegen.
Sondern die Zellen, die diese Pheromone wahrnehmen, die sind im Gehirn völlig anders verschaltet bei Mensch und Tier. Also die sind so verschaltet, dass sie reflektorisch eine Reaktion auslösen. Also wie so ein Kniesehnenreflex. Und deswegen …
Also wie ein Reflex sozusagen.
Wie ein Reflex. Also wenn ich ein Pheromon rieche, dann werde ich dich den Duft gezwungen, ein Tier wird gezwungen, eine bestimmte Handlung oder eine bestimmte Reaktion zu zeigen.
Menschen auch?
Menschen, wenn es Pheromone sind, auch. So wäre die Definition, also sonst sind es keine Pheromone.
Ja okay, aber wozu kann mich denn der Duft zwingen?
Das muss jetzt keine Handlung sein, das können auch hormonelle Veränderungen sein. Das gibt es im Tierreich ja auch. Da lösen Pheromone Hormonveränderungen aus oder ähnliches. Aber es können auch Handlungen sein. Also beim Menschen weiß man zum Beispiel, dass es über den Achselschweiß so etwas wie Angst, die man hat, dass die Menschen in diesem zustand ein Pheromon produzieren, dessen Molekül wir leider nicht kennen. Aber man kann eben Angstschweiß an sich nehmen, da ist es drin und kann das dann bei Mitmenschen testen. Und dann muss ja dieses Angstschweißprodukt sozusagen, dieser Angstschweiß muss bei einem Mitmenschen, wenn es ein Pheromon ist, bei jedem Mitmenschen, bei dem ich es teste, immer die gleiche reproduzierbare Antwort auslösen.
Das heißt man kommuniziert quasi eine Angst in die Luft?
Genau. Das haben alle Tiere, die wir bisher angeschaut haben, die haben so ein Angstpheromon. Das wirkt natürlich bei uns nicht, sondern bei jedem Tier extra. Es gibt beim Goldfisch ein Angstpheromon, das nur bei Goldfischen wirkt. Es gibt bei Hunden ein Angstpheromon, es gibt bei Rehen ein Angstpheromon,dass man kennt, also man kann richtige Duftzäune machen mit Angstpheromonen. So dass dann diese Angstdüfte zum Beispiel das Tier der gleichen Art, dass diesen Angstduft reicht, bei dem auch Angst erzeugen und es zum Beispiel zum Weglaufen bewegen. Und beim Menschen weiß man nun, dass der Schweiß des Angstduftes bei jedem Menschen eine gleiche vorhersagbare Wirkung auslöst. Interessanterweise, also was die Psychologen, Bettina Pause, eine Professorin in Düsseldorf, getestet hat, Aufmerksamkeitssteigerung, Konzentrationssteigerung. Also man wird aufmerksam und vorsichtig, was passiert da irgendwie?
Interessanterweise Empathie beim Menschen kann man nachweisen, dass die Empathie auslöst. Und auch so ein bisschen Angst. Aber nicht jetzt so, dass ich jetzt irgendwie weglaufe. Also man kann die Angstparameter damit steigern. Also da würden wir jetzt vermuten, es gibt ein Angstpheromon. Wir kennen allerdings weder das Pheromon noch kennen wir den Sensor. Denn man braucht natürlich für jeden Pheromonduft, genau wie für einen normalen Blütenduft oder so einen Duft, braucht man natürlich auch einen Empfänger, einen Sensor. Es gibt auch einen Pheromonrezeptor. Die Maus hat 300 zu den 1000 Duftrezeptoren, die sie hat in der Nase, hat sie noch 300 Pheromonrezeptoren. Wir Menschen haben 350 Duftrezeptoren und haben noch fünf Pheromonrezeptoren.
Fünf nur?
Fünf, warum auch immer. Wir haben die alle abgeschaltet.
Aber wir wissen, was diese fünf auslösen?
Nein leider nicht. Wir kennen die Gene für diese fünf Rezeptoren. Weil die schauen anders aus als die Duftrezeptorgene. Die kann man im Genom nachschauen des Menschen und können feststellen, wir haben noch fünf von denen, die funktionieren auch noch. Und wir können sie alle fünf in der Nase der Menschen auch nachweisen. Die gibt es also auch noch in der Nase des Menschen. Und konnten jetzt vor zwei Jahren zum ersten Mal einen Duft finden, um einen dieser fünf Rezeptoren zu aktivieren. Das heißt also, wenn man so ein Gen kennt, kann man das Gen isolieren, das machen wir ja hier jeden Tag im Labor und kann dann dieses Gen sozusagen in andere Zellen einbauen, die jetzt keine Pheromonzellen sind und kann diese anderen Zellen, Nierenzellen nehmen wir meistens dafür her, können diese anderen Zellen zwingen, dass sie diesen einen Pheromonrezeptor des Menschen herstellen. Dass sie also in ihrer Membran Pheromonrezeptoren haben.
Und was macht dann dieses Pheromon, wenn es aufschlägt beim Menschen?
Dann haben wir also tausende von Düften drüber gejagt, um einen Duft zu finden, der diesen Rezeptor aktiviert. Das ist ja das erste Problem. Und haben dann interessanterweise mit Parfümeuren zusammen, die gesagt haben, es gibt Düfte, die beim Menschen irgendwas bestimmtes machen. Und einer dieser wichtigen Düfte heißt Hedion. Hedion ist eigentlich ein Duft, der aus der Magnolie stammt und der sehr häufig in Parfüms verwendet wird. Vor allem jetzt in diesem Knowledge vorkommt. Dieses Knowledge, dieser Wissensduft der Uni, der enthält ein Drittel Hedion. Obwohl wir damals noch gar nicht wussten, was er tut. Weil er nämlich ganz bestimmte kommunikationsfördernde Eigenschaft, sagen die Parfümeure, hat angeblich. Und was man nun zeigen konnte ist, dass dieser Duft Hedion tatsächlich einen dieser menschlichen Pheromonrezeptoren aktiviert. Und dann haben wir gesagt, aber was macht er dann mit dem Menschen? Dann haben wir die Menschen also ins Kernspin gelegt und der Duft riecht eigentlich fast gar nicht oder ganz schwach.
Und haben den Menschen, obwohl sie eigentlich davon gar nichts gerochen haben, diesen Duft im Kernspin riechen lassen. Und was wir gesehen haben ist, dass der bei jedem Menschen, den wir da reingelegt haben, Mann oder Frau, immer ein kleines Kerngebiet im Hypothalamus aktiviert, das sonst von Düften gar nicht aktiviert wird. Nämlich ein kleines Zentrum im Hypothalamus des Gehirns, das für die Hormonregulation zuständig ist. Und bei Frauen sogar zehn mal stärker als bei Männern aktiviert dieser Duft dieses Zentrum.
Und was macht das Zentrum?
Da haben wir gesagt was macht das? Die Psychologen haben nicht richtig gewusst, was sie alles machen sollen und dann sind wir zu den Ökonomen gegangen. Axel Ockenfels Ist einer der berühmtesten deutschen Ökonomen in Köln. Und der Axel Ockenfels hat dann diesen Duft im ökonomischen Test untersucht. Weil die Parfümeure haben ja gesagt, ihr ändert irgendwas an der Kommunikation, am Vertrauen, irgendwie in diese Richtung zum Menschen. Und die haben nun tatsächlich gefunden, das haben wir jetzt tim letzten Jahr mit ihnen veröffentlicht auch die Arbeit, dass dieser Duft die Pheromonrezeptoren aktiviert und das Vertrauen zwischen Menschen dramatisch signifikant verändert. Das Vertrauen wird in diesen Tests, das nennt man Reziprozität, dieses Verhalten. Also Vertrauen heißt, wie du mir so ich dir. Also wenn ich einem anderen Menschen was gebe, dann habe ich ein gewisses Vertrauen, dass der mir irgendwie bei Gelegenheit was zurückgibt.
Oder wenn ich dem anderen was böses tue, dann kann ich auch relativ drauf vertrauen, dass wenn der die Chance hat, sich wieder zu rächen, dass er das auch tut. Das ist ein typisch menschliches Verhalten, das nur die Menschen oder Menschenaffen überwiegend haben. Also ein Hund würde jetzt nicht dem anderen Hund seine Bratwurst abtreten, in dem Vertrauen, dass wenn der andere mal eine Bratwurst hat, dass er ihm die zurück gibt. Also das ist klar. Und dieses Vertrauen kann man testen über solche Spieltheorien. Das heißt irgendein Mensch kriegt 5000 Euro und er kann jetzt dem anderen was abgeben. Wenn er dem anderen was abgibt, dann weiß er, dass wenn der andere ihm von dem was er ihm abgibt wieder was zurückgibt, dann ist die Spielregel so, dass er dann zehnmal so viel zurück kriegt, wie er ihm abgegeben hat. So jetzt kann er ihm mal was abgeben in dem Vertrauen, der wird mir schon wieder was zurückgeben. Der kann aber auch sagen, nein ich behalte meine 5000 Euro und fertig und ich traue dem anderen nicht über den Weg. Und diese Spiele macht man da. Und wenn man da die Tischdecke mit diesem Hedion beduftet, so haben die das gemacht, ohne dass die Leute überhaupt was rochen, dann hat sich dieses Verhalten dramatisch verstärkt.
Also man verstärkt mit diesem Duft das Vertrauen, die Kommunikation zwischen Menschen. Und das war eigentlich diese relativ bahnbrechende Entdeckung, die wir da mit den Ökonomen zusammen gemacht haben.
Wow.
Das ist das erste Pheromon des Menschen …
Vielleicht sollte man mal mit dem Parfüm nach Washington gehen und das weiße Haus einduften.
Man könnte jetzt auch zu Union Berlin gehen und die Fußballer einduften, weil es bei denen natürlich auch immer um Vertrauen geht. Das heißt also, wenn ich einem Mitspieler immer den Ball gebe, dann vertraue ich drauf, dass wenn der den Ball hat, den zurück gibt. Wenn der mir den Ball nicht zurück gibt, dann kriegt der auch bald keinen Ball mehr. Weil das ist dann die negative Reziprozität sozusagen. Also das spielt überall eine Rolle, das Vertrauen. Und ich glaube der wichtige Punkt ist auch, weil die Leute immer denken, Pheromone haben automatisch was mit Sexualität zu tun, das ist natürlich quatsch. Also auch bei Tieren, bei den Mäusen, die haben 300 Pheromonsensoren, also 300 Pheromondüfte für unterschiedlichste Kommunikationsprozesse. Und Sexualität spielt vielleicht bei 10-20% davon eine Rolle, aber 80% der Pheromone auch bei Mäusen beschäftigen sich mit allgemeinen Sachen. Wie ich habe Angst oder ich bin der Boss.
Die regulieren auch über Pheromone die Rangordnung, das ist mein Revier, das wird über ein Pheromon gekennzeichnet und all diese Dinge. Also da gibt es ganz viele Kommunikationsinformationen, die gar nichts mit Sexualität zu tun haben, die aber in dieser chemischen Sprache auch über Düfte kodiert werden. Und drum sollten wir bei uns jetzt auch nicht immer daran denken, dass wenn wir im Internet unter Pheromone nachschauen, Millionen Hits und immer diese blödsinnigen Sexualgeschichten. Wird vielleicht auch eins geben. Also wir können wahrscheinlich den Eisprung der Frau riechen, das wäre also so ein Pheromon, das uns dann bewegt, uns Männer vielleicht bewegt, eher an diesen Tagen mit der Frau mehr Kontakt zu haben. Aber im Grunde genommen gibt es viele andere. Also es gibt sicher ein Mutterbrustpheromon beim Menschen auch, um die Mutterbrust zu erkennen. Jede Menschenmutterbrust hat ihren eigenen Duft, das wäre so ein Pheromon. Also das ist eben im Hedion, deswegen hat das Hedion eben die kommunikative Eigenschaft.
Und der Rektor hat damals gesagt, ja ich möchte auch, dass die Uni irgendwie modern und jugendlich ist, drum kamen so Zitrusdüfte und Bergamotte rein. Und er sagte, um konzentriert zu sein, ist man am besten auch entspannt. Also es soll auch ein Entspannungsduft rein. Und drum haben wir damals wissenschaftlich gerade sehr viel an Entspannungsdüften gearbeitet. Also Düfte, die wir einatmen, über den Blutweg unser Gehirn erreichen und im Gehirn an Rezeptoren andocken, Duftmoleküle, die durch die Atmung ins Gehirn kommen, an Rezeptoren andocken, die mit Entspannung zu tun haben, nämlich die mit Beruhigung und Schlaf zu tun haben. Nennen sich GABA-Rezeptoren, haben gar nichts mit Riechen zu tun. Sondern sind Neurotransmitterrezeptoren, worüber sich Gehirnzellen unterhalten. Also wenn eine Gehirnzelle die andere hemmen will, dass Ruhe einkehrt, dann schüttet das GABA aus. Und diese GABA-Rezeptoren sind auch Kanäle, die sind Angriffspunkt aller Schlafmittel. Valium, also Benzodiazepine, Barbiturate, Propofol, Alkohol wirkt alles auf diese GABA-Rezeptoren und bringt uns damit zum Schlafen.
Und da gibt es eben Düfte, die wir gefunden haben, inzwischen fast 50 Stück und einer davon ist hier drin, das ist der Gardenienduft, der macht das gleiche wie Valium. Geht an die gleiche Bindestelle wie Valium, von Schlafrezeptoren, und bringt dann Mensch und Tier zum Einschlafen, oder beruhigt, angstlösend, je nach Konzentration eben auch beruhigend, schlaffördernd. Und das ist da auch drin, um eben eine Entspannung und Stresslösung zu machen. Also insofern ist eigentlich…
Ich bin schon ganz kurz davor, alle meine Mikrofone hier mit diesem Parfüm einzusprühen, um irgendwie maximale Beruhigung und Entspannung herbeizuführen.
Das Sensationelle ist ja eigentlich, dass es das erste Parfüm ist glaube ich oder eines der ersten, die sozusagen auf dem umgekehrten Weg erstellt wurden. Also normal hat ein Parfümeur die große Auswahl aus 1000 Düften irgendwas zusammen zu mischen, das einen neuen Duft gibt. Und jetzt sind wir umgekehrt vorgegangen.
Wirkungsorientiert sozusagen.
Wir haben über 100 Düfte in unserer Forschung auf ihre Wirkung beim Menschen untersucht und wissen, was die beim Menschen machen, in unseren letzten 20 Jahren Forschung hier. Und haben nun nach Wirkung, wie der Rektor es haben wollte, aktivierend, beruhigend und kommunikativ, oder animalisch vielleicht noch, nach Wirkung Düfte zusammengestellt und haben dem Parfümeur gesagt, mach mal aus den Düften ein gutes Parfüm und da kam dann Knowledge heraus. Wird zunehmen dieser Weg, weil zunehmend die Menschen nicht nur gut riechen wollen, das ist ein Grund natürlich, muss auch gut riechen, aber für sich selber auch was gewinnen wollen aus den Düften.
Um nochmal von den Menschen und auch unseren näheren Tieren, tierischen Verwandten, den Säugetieren mal weggeht, spielen denn die Düfte auch sonst in der Natur eine Rolle? Also Pflanzen sondern sie natürlich massiv ab, Blumen natürlich vor allem. Und man weiß welche Auswirkungen das hat auf die Bienen etc. Aber kommunizieren denn auch die Pflanzen untereinander über Düfte? Können Pflanzen riechen?
Also wir wissen natürlich, dass es auch Pheromone bei Pflanzen gibt, bei Bäumen vor allem kennt man das. Das heißt also auch Bäume können einen Duft abgeben, den ein anderer Baum wahrnehmen kann. Riechen würde ich jetzt nicht gerade sagen, aber wahrnehmen. Auf den ein anderer Baum reagiert, wahrnehmen wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Aber eine luftbasierte Kommunikation.
Eine luftbasierte Kommunikation, der dann beim anderen Baum eine Reaktion auslöst. Also von Bäumen weiß man eben, dass bestimmter Schädlingsbefall zum Beispiel einen Baum motivieren kann oder dazu bringt, bestimmte Duftmoleküle freizusetzen, die der Nachbarbaum dann rezipiert und darauf reagiert und eben schon frühzeitig zum Beispiel einen Abwehrstoff dann produziert gegen diesen Schädling. Also so was kennt man tatsächlich beim Pflanzen auch. Wobei ja die Pflanzendüfte im Grunde genommen zwei Bedeutungen haben. Es gibt ja die Blütendüfte, das ist klar, die wollen anlocken, um zu bestäuben, aber viele Pflanzen haben ja auch – diese ganzen Gewürzpflanzen und ätherischen Ölpflanzen – haben ja auch Düfte, die sie benutzen, um das Gegenteil zu bewirken, nämlich Abwehr zu machen.
Also jedes Gewürz, jede Minze, jeder Rosmarin hat ja einen bestimmten Duft, ein ätherisches Öl, so nennt man das, also eine komplexe Duftmischung. Und diese Duftmischung ist hochkonzentriert. Und weil die so hoch konzentriert ist, kann die gar nicht so im Blatt drin sein, sondern die muss in speziellen Behältern sein. Das können Haare sein, das können kleine Bläschen sein, wo diese hochkonzentrierten ätherischen Ölmischungen drin sind. Das kann auch in Bläschen in der Wurzel sein oder das kann Harz sein, zum Beispiel bei einem Tannenbaum. Also diese ätherischen Öle werden hergestellt von Pflanzen, um sich zu schützen. Nämlich das sind alles Abwehrdüfte. Das wenn eben ein anderes Tier da reinbeißt, dass dieses ätherische Öl so stark ist, so intensiv ist, dass es einfach unangenehm ist. Drum werden die auch nicht freigesetzt, sondern man muss erst mal an den Pflanzen rubbeln, damit man die überhaupt riechen kann.
Aber diese ätherischen Öle können wir auch riechen natürlich. Klar die lösen ja auch bei uns alle möglichen Empfindungen aus, so Minze, Menthol oder Capsaicin im Pfeffer. Also all die Öle, die im Thymian oder Irgendwo drin sind. Die wirken in der Regel alle auch auf uns ja. Und in der Regel auch als Abwehr. Also wenn die hoch konzentriert sind, dann reizen sie bei uns einen Warn- und Schmerznerven, heißt Nervus Trigeminus im Mund und in der Nase. Und wenn man diesen Nerven, der auf alle Düfte anspricht, wenn die Konzentration zu hoch ist, dann warnt der uns. Also hohe Duftkonzentrationen können für uns gefährlich und gesundheitsschädlich sein. Sowohl durch die Einatmung wie auch dadurch, dass sie in den Körper kommen. Und drum versucht der Körper immer zu vermeiden, dass wir diese hohen Duftkonzentrationen aufnehmen. Und dazu ist dieser Nervus Trigeminus da. Und der meldet dann, jetzt tut es weh, jetzt brennt es, jetzt sticht es, jetzt ist was unangenehmes, und dann lassen wir von dem Zeug ab.
Genau das passiert bei den Pflanzen dann auch, die diese Düfte produzieren, diese ätherischen Öle, um sich zu schützen vor dem Fraß zum Beispiel von anderen. Aber die ätherischen Öle sind auch extrem starke und hochpotente Wirkstoffe gegen Viren, Bakterien und Pilze. Die bringen praktisch alles um an Mikroorganismen, was man kennt. Das sind besser Antibiotika als wir zum Teil haben. Also Cineol bringt nahezu alles um was man kennt. Und inzwischen ist es auch, dass bei der ganzen Antibiotikaresistenz inzwischen diese ätherischen Öle extrem häufig auch inzwischen Einzug in die Kliniken finden, zur Heilung von schlechtheilenden Wunden, wo kein Antibiotikum mehr hilft, da wird dann so eine ätherische Öltherapie gemacht. Da kann man dann ein Aromatogramm machen. Das heißt man nimmt die Bakterien, die in der Wunde drin sind, gibt verschiedene ätherische Öle drauf auf so Platten und schaut, bei welchen wir das am besten umgebracht und die verwendet man dann auch.
Also insofern haben die Pflanzen quasi auch eine chemische Kommunikation. Zum einen eben die Blütendüfte, um anzulocken, ätherische Öle, um eben abzuwehren. Und das sind ja auch Stoffe, die wir dann – diese ätherischen Öle – zur Gesundheitsförderung nehmen. Und wir wissen, dass viele Rezeptoren dieser ätherischen Öle auch bei uns in unserem Körper vorkommen. Die neueste Duftforschung der letzen 10 Jahre beschäftigt sich ja damit, dass diese Duftrezeptoren, die 350, in der Nase sich über unseren ganzen Körper ausgebreitet haben. Das heißt die gibt es in allen Zellen unseres Körpers, auch in einer Hautzelle, Leberzelle, Nierenzelle sind einige dieser 350 Duftrezeptoren vorhanden.
Das heißt wir riechen auch mit dem Knie?
Wenn man es sehr salopp sagen will, ja, aber es natürlich kein Riechen. Sondern auch in unserem Knie gibt es, in allen Zellen die in unserem Knie sind, gibt es einige dieser Duftrezeptoren, die natürlich jetzt keine Duftwahrnehmung machen, sondern die dazu benutzt werden, um chemische Signalstoffe, die der Körper produziert hat zum Beispiel, wahrzunehmen oder aufzunehmen und zu reagieren. Jetzt an der Haut können es auch Düfte sein, die ich auf die Haut auftrage. Die können diese Duftrezeptoren in meinen Hautzellen aktivieren. Jetzt wegen der ätherischen Öle zum Beispiel auch. Im Darm gibt es sehr viele von diesen Riechrezeptoren aus der Nase in Darmzellen. Und wenn ich jetzt also eine Orange esse, dann kriege ich ja Citronellol, Citronellal, also diese Duftstoffe aus der Orange in meinen Darm, und diese Duftstoffe können auch oder auch wenn ich jetzt ein Gewürz esse, wie eine Nelke oder einen Kümmel oder verdauensfördernden Schnaps trinke mit den Kräutern, dann kommen ja die Duftstoffe in meinen Darm.
Stimulieren diese „Duftrezeptoren“ in den Darmzellen. Und führen jetzt im Darm zum Beispiel, das ist auch gezeigt worden, zur Freisetzung von Serotonin und damit zu einer Steigerung der Peristaltik. Und ich kann also erklären, wie ich mit ätherischen Ölen, also mit Kräuterlikören oder mit bestimmten Gewürzen, die ich esse, die Verdauung fördere. Oder wir haben gefunden, wie man mit einem Duft, Sandelholzduft zum Beispiel, da gibt es den Duftrezeptor in Hautzellen, da kann man das Wachstum der Hautzellen über diesen Rezeptor beeinflussen, dass die schneller wachsen und sich schneller bewegen. Und mit Kliniken zusammen haben wir das auch gemacht und das wird auch schon eingesetzt inzwischen in der Medizin. Wundheilen beschleunigen um ein Drittel. Durch die Stimulation dieser Duftrezeptoren.
Höre ich da jetzt so ein bisschen raus, dass man hier eigentlich so ein bisschen auf dem Pfad ist, medizinische Heilungsprozesse quasi über so eine Art Körperkommunikation durch entsprechende Botenstoffe zu organisieren? Dass man eigentlich fast nur noch irgendwie Durchsagen macht im Körper und sagt, ja hier da mal anfangen zu reparieren, du kannst das schon alleine?
Also ich würde es jetzt eher mal umgekehrt sehen. Also ich glaube, dass wir ja schon lange wissen, dass Körperzellen im Gehirn überall, dass die Rezeptoren an den Oberflächen tragen, die für bestimmte körpereigene Stoffe, Hormone, zuständig sind, Serotonin, Dopamin, Adrenalin haben wir alle schon gehört, und dass über diese Stoffe diese Rezeptoren die Funktion von Körperzellen beeinflusst werden kann. Also ich kann mit Adrenalin meinen Herzschlag beschleunigen oder verändern und solche Dinge. Und was wir jetzt gefunden haben ist eigentlich, dass wir nun eine riesige neue Gruppe von Membranen oder Rezeptoren, nämlich diese Duftrezeptoren gefunden haben, dass die auch in den Körperzellen alle vorkommen und dass sich die ebenso wie Serotonin- oder Dopamin-Rezeptoren verwenden kann, um die Funktion von Körperzellen zu beeinflussen. Und zwar sowohl in gesunden Zellen, wie auch in kranken Zellen.
Denn was das spannende ist, der Forschung der letzten Jahre ist, dass wir bei nahezu allen Krebsarten und Tumorarten, die wir angeschaut haben beim Menschen, Leberkrebs, Lungenkrebs, Darmkrebs, Blasenkrebs, alle diese Tumorarten, die stellen einige – Prostatakrebs vor allem – einige dieser Riechrezeptoren aus der Nase in riesigen Mengen her. Warum wissen wir nicht. Also eine Prostatakrebszelle ist voll aufgefüllt mit einem Riechrezeptor aus den Riechzellen der Nase, die für Veilchen, eine Komponente, ein Molekül, das im Veilchenduft vorkommt, Beta-Ionon Heißt dieses Molekül. Und diese Prostatakarzinomzellen stellen alle dieses Betaionon, also die Veilchenrezeptoren her. Warum sie es tun haben wir keine Ahnung. Aber was wir zeigen konnten ist, dass wenn man die mit Veilchenduft simuliert, diese Prostatakrebszellen aus der Klinik eben, aus dem OP kriegt, dann stoppt der Veilchenduft über diesen Rezeptor das Wachstum der Zellen.
Also es gibt ein Signal in den Zellkern, hör auf zu wachsen. In den Hautzellen dieser Sandelholzrezeptor, der macht das Gegenteil. Wenn man den in Hautzellen stimulieren, dann gibt der ein Signal in den Zellkern und sagt, wachse immer schneller. Also was diese Rezeptoren für Signalwege anschalten, das kann sehr unterschiedlich sein. Aber bei Tumoren finden wir jetzt eigentlich praktisch bei allen, die wir bisher angeschaut haben, immer, dass man durch die Zugabe durch die Simulation des Riechrezeptors, das Tumorwachstum nahezu reduzieren oder hemmen kann. Also da haben wir jetzt einen Rezeptor für das Leberkarzinom gefunden, Zytonelal, der stoppt Leberkarzinomwachstum. Wir haben ein Lungenkarzinom. Jetzt haben wir gerade einen neuen auch für Darmkrebs einen Rezeptor, Troenan heißt der, das sei ein Duftstoff aus der Ligusterblüte, der stoppt das Wachstum oder reduziert das Wachstum von Darmkrebs oder Blasenkrebs, da arbeiten wir gerade dran, da gibt es auch einen.
Und das Interessante zum Beispiel bei Blasenkrebs ist, dass dieser Duftrezeptor, der in den Blasenkrebszellen vorkommt, dass der auch dann, wenn die Blasenkrebszellen zerfallen, im Urin ausgeschieden wird. Und den können wir auch im Urin nachweisen. Also in dieser neuen Arbeit, die wir gerade veröffentlicht haben, ist, dass man tatsächlich zeigen kann, dass sich jetzt das als diagnostischen Marker nehmen kann. Ich kann also jetzt im Urin vom Blasenkrebspatienten zeigen, dass die Krebs haben, weil ich diesen Riechrezeptor da drin in großen Mengen finde. Also es ist auch ein Marker. Also bei Prostata wusste man eh schon, ich kann eine gesunde Prostatazelle von einer Krebszelle allein durch die Zahl der Riechrezeptoren für diesen Veilchenrezeptor unterscheiden. Die Krebszellen sind voller Veilchenrezeptoren, die gesunden Zellen haben praktisch ganz wenige oder gar keine.
Das heißt die Diagnose wird extrem vereinfacht?
Diagnose kann sein. Wir haben gerade für Brustkrebs zum Beispiel einen Rezeptor gefunden, der kommt nur im Brustkrebs vor. Dieser Riechrezeptor, außer in der Nase, gibt es den nur in Brustkrebszellen. Und wenn jetzt dieser Brustkrebs zum Beispiel eine Metastase macht irgendwo an einer anderen Stelle des Körpers, dann kann ich die Metastase daran erkennen, dass das eine Brustkrebsmetastase ist, weil der Rezeptor drin vorkommt. Bis jetzt wussten wir immer nie genau, wo kommt die Metastase her, was ist der Primärtumor? Und an dem Rezeptor kann ich es jetzt erkennen. Aber wir können auch den Herzschlag zum Beispiel bei Ihnen jetzt über einen Riechrezeptor hochsetzen oder runtersetzen die Herzfrequenz, verändern. Ich kann Ihr Herz schneller schlagen lassen oder langsamer. Also man riecht auch mit dem Herzen gut sozusagen. Wir haben eine ganze Menge von Riechrezeptoren im menschlichen Herzen gefunden und einen davon eben gerade charakterisiert und veröffentlicht, der spricht auf Fettsäuren an. Wir können Fettsäure riechen klar.
Man kann jetzt irgendwie Olivenöl riechen oder kann Kokosöl riechen und Butter riechen. Und diese Fette gibt es ja auch im Blut, Blutfette, und deswegen ist klar, dass dieser Riechrezeptor für diese Fettsäuren, für diese Fette, die in der Nase natürlich wichtig sind für diese Öle und so, Kokosöl, die gibt es auch im Herzen. Und wenn ich das dann simuliere in Herzzellen des Menschen, die wir aus der Klinik auch kriegen von Herzen, dann kann ich zeigen, dass ich mit dem einen Duft das Herz beschleunigen kann, die Herzfrequenz, und ich habe aber auch einen Duft, wo ich die Herzfrequenz reduzieren kann. Jetzt könnte ich also, nachdem wir am Anfang schon gesagt haben, Duftmoleküle können in unseren Körper gelangen über die Atmung, über die Lunge gehen sie in unser Blut, über das Essen gehen sie in unser Blut, über das Einreiben in der Haut kann ich die Duftmoleküle innerhalb von 10 Minuten im Blut nachwiesen. Also ich kann über das Einreiben von bestimmten Düften über dem Herzen beispielsweise auch diese Düfte in das Blut bringen und damit auch in das Herz hin und das Herz dann langsamer schlagen lassen.
Also das ist ja das faszinierende an den Düften im Gegensatz zum Sehen und Hören. Also Duftmoleküle werden ja von uns inkorporiert, also die Wellen vom Licht oder Schall, die gehen ja einfach durch den Körper durch, aber Duftmoleküle gehen in unseren Körper rein, die bleiben drin. Die nehme wir auf, das wird Bestandteil unseres Körpers. Und mit denen machen wir auch was, die verarbeiten wir, die wirken überall womöglich durch den Blutweg. Und auf diese Weise haben wir jetzt eigentlich aus meiner Sicht sensationell eine völlig neue Gruppe von Rezeptoren gefunden, wahnsinnig viele sogar, über 200 wissen wir schon, dass sie in Geweben vorkommen von den 350, die wahrscheinlich klinisch eine enorme Bedeutung kriegen werden, weil man die überall verwenden kann für alle möglichen Zwecke. Denn in jeder Körperzelle gibt es einige von denen. Wir wissen nicht genau warum diese speziellen da hergestellt werden. Weil jede Körperzelle hat das gesamte Genom des Menschen und kann selber entscheiden, welche der Gene aktiviere ich?
Also in jeder Körperzelle des Menschen kommen die 22.000 Gene, die wir überhaupt nur aktiveren können, vor, mehr haben wir ja nicht. Und davon wird die Hälfte angeschaltet in einer Zelle üblicherweise. Aber eine Leberzelle schaltet natürlich andere 10.000 Gene an als eine Lungenzelle oder eine Gehirnzelle, weil sie ja andere Eiweiße und Rezeptoren braucht. Aber es gibt eben in allen Körperzellen unter den 100 oder 1000 am höchsten angeschalteten Genen gibt es immer einige Riechrezeptorgene. Und das muss eine Bedeutung haben, sonst wird ein Gen nicht angeschaltet. Also jedes Anschalten wird unter ganz hohem Evolutionsdruck wird das sofort abgestellt, wen das keinen Sinn macht. Wir können es bei vielen Geweben bisher noch nicht sagen, was die Funktion ist, weil wir leider – und das ist jetzt ein ganz wichtiger Punkt in unserer Forschung von den 350 Riechrezeptoren des Menschen erst ungefähr von 20%, also von 70 vielleicht den aktivierenden Duft kennen.
Also fast 300 Riechrezeptoren des Menschen wissen wir nicht, was der passende Schlüssel ist, um den zu aktivieren, der Duft ist. Und solange ich nicht weiß was der Duft ist, kann ich natürlich auch nicht studieren, was in einer Leber- oder in einer Lungenzelle, die diesen Rezeptor trägt, was der Duft dann macht, ich muss ja erst mal einen Rezeptor aktivieren können.
Das heißt man kann den Rezeptor als solchen schon erkennen, man sieht, das ist ein Rezeptor? Weil so wie er biologisch aufgebaut ist …
Die sind alle ganz ähnlich, schauen alle ähnlich aus, und haben ganz hohe Identität in ihren Sequenzen, aber …
Aber man kann der Struktur selber nicht unmittelbar ansehen, was der Schlüssel ist?
Was der Duft ist. Nein, wir versuchen das über Molekular Modeling zu machen, haben jetzt 3-4 interessante Arbeiten gemacht, dass wir am Computer den Rezeptor nachbauen, dieses Schloss nachbauen, also die Aminosäuren, und schauen, welcher Schlüssel passt denn da rein, um Vorhersagen zu treffen, auch welcher Schlüssel passen könnte. Das ist richtiges Schloss-Schlüssel-Prinzip, ja. Aber auch das ist schwierig noch. Also bei ein paar ist es uns gelungen dann, aber wir sind immer noch weit entfernt. Aber ich glaube, dass man das Potenzial überhaupt nicht einschätzen kann, dass diese Riechrezeptoren in Zukunft haben werden, weil sie eben überall vorkommen, benutzt werden können, also in gesunden Zellen, um die Zellen zu bestimmten Prozessen zu veranlassen. Also wir haben jetzt gerade einen Riechrezeptor, an dem wir arbeiten mit einer Wiener Gruppe, der blockiert die Magensäurefreisetzung. Also brauch ich jetzt kein Kompensan mehr oder brauch kein Omeprazol mehr, und kann über Duft die Freisetzung von Magensäure in den Magensäurezellen blockieren. Es gibt unendlich viele Möglichkeiten.
Da kriegt ja der Begriff des Riechorgans eine ganz andere Dimension, weil es eigentlich gar kein Organ gibt, was nicht riecht?
Genau, also es hat nichts mit Riechen zu tun dann, muss man sagen, das ist einfach der falsche Ausdruck. Ich habe immer gesagt, ich zahle die teuerste Flasche Champagner, wenn mir einer mal einen anderen Namen sagt für diese Art von Rezeptoren in Organen. Also Duftrezeptor, Riechrezeptor ist ja alles eigentlich Blödsinn, weil die riechen nicht und nehmen auch keine Düfte wahr. Das können auch Stoffe sein, die der Körper selber herstellt. Also in der Prostata wissen wir zum Beispiel, dass dieser Veilchenduft, dieses Beta-Ionon-Molekül, das hat eine hohe Strukturähnlichkeit mit Testosteron an einer bestimmten Stelle. Und deswegen kann auch ein Abbauprodukt des Testosterons durch diese Strukturähnlichkeit, an dieser Stelle ist sozusagen der Schlüssel, auch passend für den Rezeptor. Also die Rezeptoren sind wie so ein normales Schloss, da habe ich einen Schlüssel und ich kann diesen Schlüsselbund hinten haben, das stört das Schloss gar nicht. Und genauso ist es mit den Rezeptoren auch. Also wenn das Testosteron-Molekül, wenn da dieser Teil des Moleküls in das Schloss passt, dann kann der das Schloss aufsperren.
Und bei der Prostata wissen wir, dass das zum Beispiel auch ein Hormonrezeptor ist, dieser Riechrezeptor, also durch Hormone aktiviert werden kann. Also es können viele körpereigene Stoffe sein, die wir jetzt noch gar nicht kennen, die diese Rezeptoren dann in den Zellen aktivieren, das müssen jetzt nicht Düfte sein. Also jetzt in der Lunge, da kann man sich gut vorstellen, weil da kommen ja Düfte beim Einatmen hin, da haben wir jetzt auch einen Rezeptor gefunden, zum Beispiel in den Bronchien, das sind ja diese zuführenden Gefäße, um die Luft in die Lunge zu führen, und da sind Muskeln außen rum. Und wenn jetzt Asthmatiker oder Allergiker sind, die schütten Histamin aus und Histamin führt dazu, dass diese Muskeln um diese Bronchien sich kontrahieren und zusammenziehen und die Luft verengen, die Luftzufuhr verengen. Und jetzt haben wir einen Duft gefunden, der das Gegenteil macht. Also dieser Riechrezeptor in den Bronchien, den wir gefunden haben, der erweitert die Bronchien und lässt die erschlaffen, obwohl Histamin da ist. Also da könnte man vielleicht sogar kontrahierte Muskeln bei Allergikern oder so wieder weit stellen über den Duft.
Also die können unterschiedlichste Funktionen haben diese Moleküle, wo wir noch gar keine Vorstellungen haben, was die alles machen können.
Um es mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, über die Riechforschung kommt man mittlerweile in Bereiche, die weit über dieses olfaktorische Spiel hinausgehen. Es macht sich eher so eine Welt der Körperkommunikation auf die noch ganz am Anfang steht, wo man überhaupt noch nicht weiß, wie weit das trägt, aber wo das Potenzial offenbar doch sehr groß ist.
Und das in der Pharmakologie. Also das ist ja das, was immer oft übersehen wird und auch nicht gern gehört wird von vielen Firmen, die eben Düfte verwenden und herstellen, dass Düfte eben, wenn sie eine Wirkung auf den Menschen haben und wenn sie nicht diese subjektive Wirkung über die Konditionierung haben im Gehirn über die Nase, dass Düfte natürlich auch chemische Stoffe sind, genau wie Medizinstoffe, die pharmakologische Wirkung haben können. Vorhersagbare, bei jedem Menschen gleiche. Und das müssen nicht nur die Riechrezeptoren sein, die sind natürlich dazu da im Körper, die überall verteilt sind, so was zu machen. Das können aber auch, wie ich vorher gezeigt habe, Gehirnrezeptoren sein. Diese GABA-Rezeptoren, die auf Valium ansprechen, die eben auch durch Düfte beeinflusst werden können. Also Düfte, das müssen wir einfach zunehmend lernen, sind Pharmaka, haben pharmakologische Wirkungen, deren Ausmaß wir noch gar nicht erkennen, deren Einsatz aber schon lange bekannt ist. Denn Aromatherapie ist ja im Grunde genommen natürlich sehr esoterisch angehaucht.
Aber Aromatherapie hat natürlich auch ihre Jahrtausende alte Grundlage in der chinesischen Medizin, in der japanischen Medizin, überall haben die schon gewusst, dass sie mit Düften auch pharmakologische, vorhersagbare Wirkungen erzielen können. Und ich glaube das ist diese ganz neue große Ära, die beginnen wird, die sich dann vielleicht sogar auf die Wirkung von Parfüms ausbreiten wird. Dass ich also Parfüms als Wirkdüfte auch nehme.
Das heißt es riecht nicht nur gut, sondern macht auch gesund?
Das hat auch bestimmte Eigenschaften. Ob es jetzt gesund macht, aber die ich eben verwenden kann, um es in bestimmte physiologischen Prozessen einzusetzen. Also ich würde mir jetzt nie ein Parfüm auf die Haut sprühen, auf deutsch gesagt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wir haben über 20 Riechrezeptoren in Hautzellen drin, wir haben andere in den Melanozyten, die die schwarze Farbe, den Teint machen, drin. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Düfte sind, um Rezeptoren zu aktivieren. Also ich wäre jetzt vorsichtig, Parfüm auf die Haut zu sprühen.
Wohin denn sonst?
Ja früher hat man das nie auf die Haut gesprüht, das ist ganz neu.
Sondern?
Früher hat man es immer auf die Kleidung gesprüht, auf die Perücken, irgendwo, aber doch nicht auf die Haut. Das ist ganz neu eigentlich, dass die Leute jetzt immer denken, das muss auf die Haut, weil dann irgendwie der eigene Körperduft sich dann vermischt. Das ist ja auch noch eklig, muss man auch nicht haben. Also eigentlich macht es keinen Sinn. Also im Grunde genommen würde ich ein Parfüm auf die Kleidung sprühen, auf die Perücken, in die Haare von mir aus, aber nicht auf die Haut. Und es ist ja auch viel einfacher. Gut dann sagen die, ach da kriege ich ja Flecken auf der Kleidung. Da sage ich, lieber Flecken auf der Kleidung als auf der Haut. Ich selber konditioniere mich mit Düften. Ich kann das vielleicht jedem nur noch raten, der zuhört, das beste Mittel, um sich persönlich sozusagen zu verstärken in seinen Reaktionen, die man haben will, sind Düfte. Also wenn jemand nicht schlafen kann, wenn jemand Konzentrationsschwierigkeiten hat beim Arbeiten, er kann sich irgendeinen Duft nehmen, das ist völlig wurscht, jeden Duft dieser Welt.
Und kann sich den auf sein Sakko sprühen, Parfüm nehmen oder was immer er gern hat. Und wenn er das nur nimmt in dem Moment, in dem er konzentriert arbeitet, und macht das zehnmal hintereinander. Also den darf er sonst nie benutzen diesen Duft im Leben, nur in der einen Situation, wo er konzentriert arbeitet. Dann kann ich dem vorhersagen, dass wenn er diesen Duft riecht, wird in seinem Gehirn sofort der konzentriert arbeiten Modus eingeschaltet. Durch sein Erinnerungs- und Gedächtniszentrum. Oder wenn einer einen Duft nimmt nur vor dem Einschlafen, sonst nie, dann wird dieser Duft ihm helfen, einzuschlafen. Und den kann man sich einfach auf den Ärmel oder auf das Nachthemd sprühen oder was auch immer. Nur nicht zu viel. Denn das was wir auch wissen ist, bei Düften ist das Gegenteil wie bei anderen Dingen, viel hilft nicht viel. Also hohe Konzentrationen von Düften sind eher schädlich, das haben wir ja vorher schon gehört. Da spricht der Nervus Trigeminus an. Also da müssen wir uns eher schützen. Also viel hilft nicht viel. Auf keinen Fall zu viele Düfte, das kann sehr schädliche Auswirkungen haben.
Also insofern, aber sich das auf den Ärmel zu sprühen ist wunderbar.
Vor sieben Jahren, 2010, wurde Ihnen ja vom Stifterverband und vom DFG der Communicator-Preis verliehen für Ihre Arbeit. Man merkt jetzt in diesem Gespräch auch warum. Sie haben es auch schon angedeutet, auch Ihre eigentliche Professorentätigkeit läuft auch langsam aus, trotzdem sind Sie ja sehr engagiert noch im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld. Seit mehreren Jahren sind Sie schon Präsident der Akademie der Wissenschaft und Künste in Nordrhein-Westfalen gewesen. Sage ich das gerade richtig?
Genau, ganz genau.
Und seit auch schon einiger Zeit auch …
Seit zwei Jahren.
Seit zwei Jahren genau der Union der deutschen Akademien der Wissenschaften. Würde mich jetzt nochmal zum Abschluss interessieren, was Ihre eigene Karriere hier für einen neuen Weg eingeschlagen hat und was das für eine Arbeit ist.
Ja es ist in der Tat so, dass wenn man im wissenschaftlichen Leben ein bisschen in Richtung Pension geht, dass dann auch die Zahl der Mitarbeiter weniger wird und dass alles immer etwas eingeschränkter wird. Und damit kriegt man freie Valenzen, um auch mal was anderes zu tun. Finde ich zwar auf der einen Seite schade, weil die Wissenschaft immer das ist, was am meisten faszinierend ist, und die Lehre auch. Also ich liebe ja die Lehre, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also ich kann keinen Hochschullehrer verstehen, der nicht gerne Vorlesungen hält. Also es macht mir wirklich Spaß und ich mach es gerne und ich werde es auch weiterhin so gut ich es tun kann weitermachen. Also Lehre ist was ganz wichtiges an der Uni und sollte eigentlich jeder auch für sich … Jeder hat natürlich andere Talente. Und ich habe vielleicht dieses Talent, das auch gut zu machen, deswegen sind die Studenten auch ganz begeistert. Schade, dass der Lehrstuhl natürlich hier aufhört und dass die Riechforschung in Bochum, muss man auch sagen, damit zu Ende geht. Also der Nachfolger von mir wird keine Riechforschung mehr machen.
Und das ist ja immer etwas bedauerlich. Und auch weltweit wird sich dann mit diesen Themen, die wir jetzt gerade gehört haben, wird sich niemand mehr damit beschäftigen. Also ich kenne in der ganzen Welt kein einziges Labor, das sich mit diesem Riechen beim Menschen beschäftigt auf dieser Ebene, im Moment noch.
Und das bei dem Potenzial, was wir gerade ausgemacht haben.
Und das bei dem Potenzial. Aber ich hoffe, dass die ganzen Arbeiten, die wir jetzt produzieren eben dazu beitragen, dass sich eben doch der eine oder andere sich überlegt, da könnte doch noch genug Potenzial sein, da könnte auch noch genug zu forschen sein. Und das dann irgendwo in der Welt … in Korea fangen sie jetzt an, das zu machen. Aber ansonsten es zu tun. Aber durch diese freien Valenzen kam ich natürlich auch in die Akademie der Wissenschaft, also eigentlich durch die wissenschaftlichen Leistungen kam ich in die Akademie der Wissenschaft in Düsseldorf und wurde dann eben zum Präsidenten gewählt und die Akademien sind ja schon eine uralte Institution, die zum Teil 200-300 Jahre alt ist natürlich, die großen Akademien in Berlin und in Bayern und Leopoldina und so. Die Düsseldorfer wurden erst nach dem Krieg gegründet, das war sozusagen eine Neugründung. Aber alle haben Ziel, eben nicht nur heutzutage Wissenschaftskommunikation innerhalb der Professoren zu betreiben, sondern eben auch Arbeitsakademien zu sein und nach außen zu wirken.
Also in Akademien werden ja die Mitglieder gewählt. Es sollten aus jeder Sparte – also in Düsseldorf gibt es eben die Ingenieure, die Naturwissenschaftler, die Geisteswissenschaftler, die Wirtschaftswissenschaftler – also alle Sparten der Universität sind abgebildet, die Künste natürlich auch. Und da sollten immer die herausragenden Vertreter aus den verschiedenen Sparten hineingewählt werden und zwar immer nur ganz wenige so. Also immer nur 3-4 der wichtigsten Leute aus der Biologie, aus der Chemie und die sollten sich zusammentun und sollten eben über bestimmte wissenschaftlich wichtige Themen intern natürlich diskutieren, Vorträge halten. Und so war es ja bisher häufig, dass diese Akademien so ein Elfenbeinturm waren, wo die Wissenschaftler sich getroffen haben im stillen Kämmerlein, sich gegenseitig Dinge vorgetragen haben und diskutiert haben und gesagt haben, es ist gut, die Außenwelt interniert uns nicht. Das hat sich aber doch grundlegend geändert in den letzten Jahren muss man sagen. Denn es ist doch sowohl von der Akademie selber heraus, aber auch von außen ein gewisser Druck gekommen, zu sagen, ihr müsst es auch nach außen tragen.
Und deswegen haben die Akademien der Wissenschaften jetzt alle eigentlich inzwischen die ganzen großen drei Aufgaben für sich in Anspruch genommen. Sie machen natürlich weiterhin diese internen Gespräche, die sie bisher auch hatten und Kommunikation zwischen den Wissenschaftlern. Aber sie sind inzwischen auch wirklich die zentralen Institutionen geworden, die völlig unabhängig, weil sie sind ja weder von einer Universität abhängig, noch von Geld, noch von Parteien oder von irgendwas politisch, die völlig unabhängig zu wichtigen Fragen der Gesellschaft sich äußern können mit den Experten, die sie ja haben. Und das ist das, was die Akademien jetzt im Moment auszeichnet, dass sie eben auch zu sehr komplexen Fragestellungen, nehmen Sie jetzt die neue Gentechnik. Also darf ich Gene des Menschen verändern?
Auch ethische und moralische Fragen.
Das ist ethisch und moralisch. Weil da sind nun die Geisteswissenschaftler drin, die Ethiker, sind die Mediziner drin, sind die Techniker drin, die die Techniken können. Also insofern, diese Fragen werden jetzt auf breiter Ebene nun von den Akademien bearbeitet und eben auch sowohl aufbearbeitet und aufbereitet in einer Form, da sind 2-3 mal im Monat jetzt öffentliche Veranstaltungen, wo dann Wissenschaftler für die Öffentlichkeit, da sind dann 200-300 interessierte Leute da, vortragen über diese Themen und das den Leuten sozusagen vermitteln auf vernünftige und verständliche Weise. Aber eben auch für die Politik und für die Gesellschaft Stellungnahmen herausgeben, die sind dann schon umfangreicher, aber die sagen einfach zur Energiewende was oder zu Energiesystemen in der Zukunft oder zur Gentechnik oder grünen Gentechnik. Also alle möglichen Dinge, oder Promotionen...
All diese Fragen, die …
All diese Fragen, aber auch solche Dinge, wie wirkt sich Wissenschaft auf die sozialen Medien aus oder die sozialen Medien auf die Wissenschaft aus. Also sehr viele Fragen, Sicherheitsfragen, relevante Fragen, Sterbehilfe und solche Dinge. Die werden jetzt da in Stellungnahmen erarbeitet. Und dann versuchen die Akademien heutzutage natürlich auch sehr stark eben die Geisteswissenschaften zu unterstützen. Also das wissen die wenigsten Menschen, die Akademien haben ein riesiges Programm für langzeitgeisteswissenschaftliche Grundlagenforschung. Das wird von Bund und Land unterstützt. Und um das Geld auch vernünftig zu verteilen, - acht Akademien gibt es in Deutschland, also in Berlin, in München, Bayern Heidelberg und so, Nordrhein-Westfalen, Hamburg, Sachsen – diese Akademien haben sich jetzt zusammengeschlossen zu einer Union.
Und diese Union der deutschen Akademien, deren Präsident ich jetzt seit zwei Jahren bin, die ist nun dafür verantwortlich, a) diese Themen der Akademien zu bündeln und übergeordnet auch mit den beiden anderen, mit Leopoldina und Acatech, das sind ja noch die Nationalakademie und die Ingenieursakademie, mit denen zusammen noch Themen zu erarbeiten und Stellungnahmen herauszugeben, dass alle zusammen arbeiten. Aber vor allem hat die Union die Aufgabe, dieses geisteswissenschaftliche Forschungsprogramm zu koordinieren und zu organisieren. Das heißt wir sind die größte Einrichtung weltweit für geisteswissenschaftliche Langzeitforschung.
Weil das ja ein Thema ist, was eigentlich an den Universitäten heute etwas unterrepräsentiert wirkt.
Genau und schon gar natürlich, wenn es um längerfristige Forschung geht. Also es gibt in der Geisteswissenschaft natürlich Fragestellungen, die sind gar nicht in einem Forscherleben zu bearbeiten, dazu reicht es gar nicht aus. Also was weiß ich, ob das jetzt Humboldt ist oder die Preußen oder die Inschriften, die es irgendwie gibt, die noch da sind seit Christi Geburt, die gesammelt und archiviert werden müssen. Also die Projekte der Akademien, dort einen Antrag kann jeder Wissenschaftler in Deutschland stellen bei den Akademien. Und die müssen mindestens eine Laufzeit von 12 Jahren haben. Es muss also ein Konzept vorgestellt werden, das so umfangreich ist und so wichtig ist, dass man sagt, 12 Jahre Forschung brauche ich da mindestens dafür, um das zu lösen dieses Problem. Und sie können aber auch 20-30-40 Jahre lang sein.
Also da geht es um die großen Philosophen von Kant und Hegel oder Luther oder solche Dinge, die dann da in ihrer ganzen Breite deren Werke erfasst werden und archiviert werden und interpretiert werden. Aber es sind auch Projekte dabei, die jetzt im Ausland laufen. Also die Maya-Sprache ist zum Beispiel ein Projekt, was gerade in der Düsseldorfer Akademie noch versucht wird zu entschlüsseln. Da kennt man erst die Hälfte dieser Hieroglyphen der Maya-Schrift, die anderen müssen wir erst entschlüsseln. Oder Mumien in Ägypten natürlich, Mumienforschung wird betrieben oder Ausgrabungen in der Türkei. Also es sind sehr viele Projekte, wie Deckenmalereien und alles mögliche. Das sind so Langzeitakademieprojekte, die jetzt die Union macht und die von unglaublicher Bedeutung sind, eben unsere kulturelle Vergangenheit zu bewahren, zu sichern und eben auch aufzuarbeiten und zu digitalisieren, so dass man sie eben dann der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellen kann.
Und nicht nur der Öffentlichkeit, sondern vor allem auch den Wissenschaftskollegen in der ganzen Welt. Also das ist eine unglaubliche Herausforderung natürlich heutzutage. Auch die Speicherung dieser Daten natürlich. Bis jetzt standen diese Bände in Bibliotheken. Also da gibt es irgendwie über Hegel oder irgendwas, gibt es also dann 30-40 Bände, die dann in Bibliotheken quadratmeterweise Platz einnehmen und die werden jetzt alle retrodigitalisiert, aber die neuen Projekte werden komplett digitalisiert von Anfang an. Und dann ich digital schon in ihren Inhalten sozusagen verändert. Also ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel Deckenmalereien jetzt schon in einer 3D-Rekonstruktion der ganzen Kirchen im Netzwerk anschauen. Und kann mir jetzt in einer barocke bayerischen Kirche eine wunderschöne Figur oben anschauen und kann schauen, welchen kleinen Gegenstand dieser Mensch in den Händen hält.
Und ob ich da jetzt in Amerika sitze oder in Mexiko oder irgendwo, kann ich jetzt auf der Homepage hier der Union kann ich dann schauen, warum der jetzt ein Zepter hat oder was auf dem Papier steht, was der in der Hand hat.
Heißt das, dass die ganze Forschungstätigkeit, die jetzt von der Union angestrebt wird, auch generell ein offenes Publikationsmodell verfolgt?
Genau. Also das soll nach außen wirklich völlig transparent und offen werden, für alle zugänglich. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine neue Plattform etabliert, die jetzt im Frühjahr in Gang gesetzt wird, auch zuerst mal mit den europäischen Akademien, auch die zu integrieren, die Projekte von denen.
Das heißt das wird gar nicht mehr über Journale publiziert, wie man das so kennt?
Es wird natürlich noch, wo es nötig ist, noch über Bücher publiziert zum Teil. Klar die klassische Geisteswissenschaft läuft natürlich immer noch über Bücher und so, aber parallel immer auch die Bücher alleine darf es nicht mehr geben, sondern alle neuen Projekte haben jetzt immer auch die digitale Version dazu. Was ein großes Problem ist mit den Verlagen natürlich, die sich dagegen mit Händen und Füßen wehren und in ???. Und sie erweitern diese Option noch in die neuen Projekte, indem sie eben nicht nur die Bücher haben, sondern dann eben so etwas wie eine 3D-Rekonstruktion haben.
Also auch echte Daten, Forschungsnetzwerke?
Daten, Forschung zusammenführen, Daten aus verschiedenen Projekten zusammenführen und daraus einen Mehrwert gewinnen. Also da gibt es unterschiedlichste neue Ansätze, die man eben über die Digitalisierung dann ontop machen kann. Nicht nur im ??? und so.
Führen Sie als Union auch diese Debatte mit, die sich ja gerade also derzeit gibt es ja die eine Front gegen die Verlage und ihr normales bisheriges Publikationswesen. Mehrere Universitäten haben sich jetzt zusammengeschlossen und haben gesagt, so machen wir das jetzt nicht mehr, wir müssen da irgendwie einen anderen Deal finden. Ist das eine Debatte, an der Sie auch mitwirken?
Klar, also wir wirken natürlich vor allem intern von uns mit. Das heißt wir Akademien haben uns ja auch in der Union zusammengeschlossen, um eben jetzt gemeinsam solche Verträge mit Verlagen auszuhandeln, um eben gemeinsam eine klare Linie zu setzen. Denn bis jetzt haben die Verlage ja oft die einzelnen Akademien und die einzelnen Projekte gegeneinander – jetzt mal negativ gesagt – ausgespielt. Mit dem haben sie den Vertrag gemacht, mit dem anderen so einen. Je nachdem wie halt die Juristen und die Vertragspartner da waren. Und jetzt ist klar, dass wir als Union mal schauen müssen, dass wir eine gemeinsame Strategie entwickeln und sagen, wir wollen ganz bestimmte Punkte, wie eben die digitale Fassung dieser ganzen Forschungsarbeiten, spätestens 2-3 Jahre nachdem der Band erschienen ist, es ist schon klar, die Verlage müssen ja auch irgendwie, die kosten ja auch was, die Verbände müssen ja auch was bezahlen.
Dann spätestens nach der und der Zeit das frei zur Verfügung ist. Und manche Dinge direkt freigestellt werden, also solche Sachen. Also das müssten wir zusammen machen. Wir kriegen von Bund und Land 65 Millionen im Jahr für diese geisteswissenschaftliche Drittmittelforschung. Das klingt jetzt zwar viel, ist natürlich im Gesamtvolumen des Forschungsvolumens natürlich lächerlich, aber für die Geisteswissenschaften ist es wirklich das zentrale Forschungsgeld natürlich, was sie sonst nirgends herkriegen. Drum geht es eben auch nur um die Geisteswissenschaften. Früher konnten auch Naturwissenschaftler was beantragen, aber das war natürlich nicht sinnvoll. Weil die brauchen ganz andere Summen diese Projekte natürlich.
Und auch eine ganz andere Organisation.
Ja. Ein Mikroskop bei mir kostet eine Million allein schon. Da ist der ganze Etat weg.
Da sind ja auch die Universitäten verhältnismäßig gut aufgestellt und bevorzugen ja auch die Naturwissenschaften in gewisser Hinsicht schon seit einiger Zeit.
Ja gut aufgestellt sind sie leider nicht.
Na im Verhältnis zu den Geisteswissenschaften.
Klar. Aber das ist eigentlich ein Skandal, dass wenn ich denke, dass außeruniversitäre Einrichtungen, Max-Planck und die ganzen Einrichtungen, die werden jetzt glaube ich seit acht Jahren jedes Jahr kriegen die 5% auf ???, jetzt 3%. Also wenn man mal zusammenstellt, die haben ihr Etat um 30-40% erhöht in den letzten Jahren und die Universitäten wurden gekürzt. Das ist eigentlich ein Unding. Und so merkt man auch, dass die ganzen Basic-Research-Bereiche, die wir auch haben hier, wenn wir die nicht über Drittmittel einwerfen würden, wir hocken auf dem ganzen alten Zeug noch von Universitäten, weil die können uns gar kein Geld geben, um diese neuen teuren Geräte, die sind ja gleich 1-2 Millionen teuer, um die überhaupt zu finanzieren, das geht gar nicht. Also das ist wirklich was, wo die Politik dringend einen Nachholbedarf hat, die Universitäten dann auch. Denn der Wettbewerb wird immer ungleicher. Ich sehe es ja bei meiner eigenen, wir haben ein tolles Thema, drum kommen die Studenten, aber die meisten wollen dann irgendwie ans Max-Planck oder Leibniz oder Fraunhofer, da haben sie einfach ganz andere Bedingungen zu arbeiten.
Da haben sie Geld und da haben sie tolle Geräte und haben alles. Das können die Universitäten sich gar nicht leisten. Wir dürfen nur die Lehre machen und die Kurse leiten. Also das ist eine Geschichte, die unerfreulich ist.
Was natürlich problematisch ist, wenn sich die Forschung von der Lehre entfernt, dann leidet ja auch die Lehre darunter.
Und wenn die besten von unseren Studenten immer dann an die anderen Institute gehen, wie gesagt, da muss man hier schon sehr attraktive Bedingungen bieten. Jetzt hier bei mir geht es, weil wir natürlich auch viel erfolgreiche Forschung machen, interessante Sachen, aber das ist für andere schonen großes Problem. Also das ist eben was die Akademien schon sehr bewegt, dass sie schauen müssen, dass man gemeinsam stärker ist und dass man dann auch gegen solche OpenAccess-Geschichten natürlich also für so etwas dann auch versucht gemeinsam eine Strategie zu entwickeln. Gut wir machen ja auch unsere Publikationen. Ich bin da immer zwiespältig bei uns in OpenAccess in meinem eigenen Arbeiten hier. Weil ich kriege mindestens in der Woche drei Angebote in einem Editorial Board eines neuen OpenAccess-Journals teilzunehmen, das aus dem Boden schießt. Und die sagen mir alle, du kannst da mitmachen und wir zahlen dir 500, 800, 1000 Euro für jeden Artikel, den du akzeptierst.
Also die kriegen so wissenschaftliche Arbeiten zugeschickt die Journale, und dann muss ein Editor die anschauen und muss die den Gutachtern geben und muss dann entscheiden, wollen wir den jetzt veröffentlichen oder nicht. Aber wenn so ein Editor 500 oder 800 oder 1000 Euro kriegt für jeden, den er akzeptiert, heißt das doch, dieser Editor akzeptiert eigentlich alles was er kriegt, weil nur dann kriegt er die 1000 Euro, sonst macht er die Arbeit umsonst. Also was ist das für ein System? Und diese OpenAccess-Journale, die da wie Pilze aus dem Boden schießen, das ist ja wie die Lizenz zum Geld drucken. Die haben einen Computer irgendwo stehen, sonst brauchen sie ja nichts mehr. Und dann suchen sie irgendwelche blöden, also Wissenschaftler, die sich dazu hergeben, diese eingesandten Publikationen zu redigieren und zu beurteilen oder sowas, kostenlos oder für wenig. Und dann stellen sie es in den Computer rein. Also die haben ja keine Infrastruktur und nichts mehr. Die brauchen ja nichts mehr. Verlangen aber dann letztendlich 2000-5000 Euro Publikationskosten von dem einreichenden Wissenschaftler.
Also ich brauche hier im Jahr für meine Arbeiten fast 50.000 Euro, muss ich persönlich bezahlen, um meine Arbeiten zu publizieren. Also ich heiß, ich kann das versuchen irgendwie über Drittmittel oder andere Mittel einzuwerben oder über den Lehrstuhl. Aber wer hat denn das Geld? Also das ist eine große Gefahr, die ich im Moment sehe. Also ich denke bloß, ??? veröffentlicht 30.000 Artikel im Jahr. 30.000 nur auf dem Computer, kriegen 4.000 Euro pro Artikel. Kann man sich mal vorstellen, Millionen nehmen die ein dafür. Also das ist doch, da fragt man sich schon, wo ist das der richtige Weg? Oder ist es so, dass sich vielleicht mit der Zeit dann doch das wieder irgendwie selektiert und die Journale wieder kaputt gehen oder so. Aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Es macht den Eindruck, als ob wir in so einer Art Startup-Phase sind, in der halt jetzt alles mögliche ausprobiert wird, weil es ja wohl offenbar einen starken Bedarf gibt für ein geändertes Publikationskonzept. Nur dessen neue Regeln, die ja auch von jedermann akzeptiert werden, die am Ende auch positive Wirkung entfalten sollen, die sind jetzt halt noch nicht Gesetz und Teil der Diskussion.
Die Qualität ist mal das erste. Und das ist meine Erfahrung, die ist bei OpenAccess-Journalen natürlich nicht mehr gegeben, weil die haben natürlich nur noch Interesse Geld zu kriegen für die Publikationen. Das ist deren Hauptinteresse. Die wollen diese Arbeit haben und wollen sie publizieren, denn dann können sie 4.000 Euro verlangen. Also es geht einfach aus meiner persönlichen Erfahrung stark auf die Qualität. Und da aber natürlich jeder Wissenschaftler sein Zeug publizieren will und wenn es noch der größte Schwachsinn ist, der hat jetzt die Gelegenheit. Früher hat er die gar nicht gehabt, das hat niemand gedruckt, aber jetzt findet er irgendein OpenAccess-Journal, wo er das alles unterbringen kann.
Fragt man sich ja, warum die Wissenschaft sich ihre Publikationswege nicht einfach selber baut.
Genau, ganz genau, das hatten wir in der Union und diskutieren wir natürlich auch da. Und ich glaube, das wäre ein ganz wichtiger Anstoß.
Ja Herr Hatt, da waren jetzt eine Menge wichtige Anstöße drin. Aber ich denke, jetzt kommen wir langsam mal zum Ende. Ich bedanke mich sehr für Ihre Ausführungen über das Riechen, das Duften und viel gelernt über, wie unser Körper denn so funktioniert und es sieht ja auch so aus, als ob da noch eine Menge zu erforschen und zu regeln ist.
Das ist in der Tat so und das ist ja auch gut so, wenn auch die zukünftigen Generationen auch was zu tun haben. Und ich glaube die haben noch genug zu tun. Und also wie gesagt, das faszinierende an diesem Thema ist einfach diese Breite, das geht von der Philosophie bis zur Psychologie und Physiologie und Ökonomie inzwischen und zur Medizin. Das ist so faszinierend, wenn man es dann auf die Tierwelt ausdehnt, dann ist das schon ein Thema, wo man schon sagen muss, es ist schade, dass es so lange so etwas wenig vom Menschen beachtet wurde, niederer Sinn, was sagte Kant? Der unnötigste aller Sinne. Also ich glaube, die Menschen nehmen mit der Zeit wahr und man sieht es auch an der ganzen medialen Aufmerksamkeiten, dass Duft doch unser Leben ganz tief beeinflussen kann und dass es viel wichtiger ist. Und unsere Nase auch viel besser ist, das muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen, unsere Nase ist viel besser als wir denken, wenn man sie nur benutzen würde.
Ja dann haben wir ja hier mit dem Thema zumindest ein gutes Näschen bewiesen für die 50. Jubiläumssendung. Jetzt bleibt mir nur noch mich zu bedanken, natürlich auch bei allen, die hier zugehört haben, nicht nur bei dieser Sendung, sondern überhaupt bei Forschergeist, und wir sind noch lange nicht am Ende. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter und bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.